[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement
Bluetooth ?
Alors bah déjà merci pour l'invitation
euh Bluetooth à cœur intermittent du
spectacle sur Twitter.
Faire pipi ou ça va aller
du tout ? Non non c'est c'est déjà fait.
Intermittent du spectacle.
Intermittent du spectacle sur Twitter.
Bidouilleur à mes heures perdu
de choses d'autre en fait.
DJ en Russie dans les stations que joker
en Russie. Exactement.
C'est pas mal.
Alors, intermittent sur Twitter
également, c'est une grande confréie.
Euh entrepreneur et enseignant, c'est le
truc que je ch systématiquement. C'est
c'est mes deux principales activités du
moment.
Bris Zax,
euh enfant enfant de l'internet de d'une
30 de plus d'une trentaine d'années, je
donnerais pas le nom précis. Euh et
comme je dis à ma grand-mère, je suis
payé pour casser.
Oui. Et et des fois reconstruire
peut-être
ça. Après, je le laisse à la charge des
clients.
Donc aujourd'hui, on va parler vie
privée, on va parler revanche porn et on
va parler censure Big Brother, comment
tordre une intelligence artificielle
pour lui faire dire n'importe quoi,
comment on peut capturer certaines
plateformes et ce qui se passe en
général en terme de cyberharcèlement, en
terme de tout un tas de choses, de
l'économie du numérique, de Bug Bounty,
Bug Bounty peut-être enfin de lock
picking avec un peu de gel et puis tout
un tas de trucs et
qui commence Zax
avec plaisir.
On prend quel sujet ? On prend le
cyberharcèlement ensuite on en verra sur
Fabrice avec peut-être un peu de
sécurité de vie privée. Non, plutôt vie
privée Fabrice
oui.
Bah le tiens cyberharcèlement parce ça
fera peut-être une bonne passe décisive
donc avec plaisir.
Euh charcèlement, je pense qu'on peut
partir d'un constat assez large. Je je
vais faire des raccourcis. Je vous
laisse corriger si vous me trouvez trop
pessimiste ou avec pas assez de
résilience.
Euh dans un monde où la cybercriminalité
se développe, euh plus les années
passent et plus j'ai l'impression de me
rendre compte que on sort d'une
conjecture pro où on sensibilise des
entreprises à essayer d'adopter ce qu'on
appelle une hygiène numérique, hein.
C'est laver son système d'information de
tout ce qui va pas et tout ce qui est
sale. Et devant cette recrudescence et
cette professionnalisation de la
cybercriminalité,
même en tant qu'acteur privé, on se rend
compte qu'on a de plus en plus de
particulier de concitoyens français qui
viennent nous voir en disant "Bon bah,
j'ai cherché sur internet, j'ai vu que
vous étiez une entreprise qui fait de la
cybersécurité
sur Syerview.
Euh oui oui oui. Du coup effectivement,
on te doit quelques bières pour cela
historiquement
avec modération loi
et réseaux sociaux. Mais au-delà de la
boutade, c'est on se rend compte qu'on a
de plus en plus de sollicitation de
particulier où d'une part, on se dit que
c'est bizarrement pas notre travail et
on ne s'y attendait pas parce que on
adresse majoritairement des
professionnels mais surtout des
particuliers qui viennent nous voir avec
une posture de enfin je pense qu'on peut
utiliser le terme forme de désespoir
parce que leur progéniture eux-mêmes
subissent des actes de cyber
malveillance au sens large. escroquerie
bancaire,
fraude à l'amour tel qu'on le connaît et
c'est très démocratisé pour
Brad Pit
Brad Pitt,
le fameux Brad Pitt effectivement
c'était peut-être pas du deep fake mais
en tout cas du beau Photoshop et du
paint et au-delà de la blague sur des
sujets beaucoup plus lourds, une jeune
génération qui est de plus en plus
exposée à du cyberharcèlement, du
revenge porn parce qu'on sait pas qui
est à l'autre bout de l'écran et des
parents démunis qui viennent nous voir
en disant "Bon bah voilà, ma gamine elle
est plus à l'école depuis 2 ans,
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ? Et ils
viennent nous solliciter. Et là se pose
le constat de est-ce qu'on est les bons
interlocuteurs d'une part et de deux
comment se faitce que malgré n dépôt de
plainte et le N dépôt de plainte des
fois c'est 4 5 sur des fenêtres
temporelles de 2 ans, on se retrouve
avec des parents qui viennent dire bah
voilà le résultat du dépôt de plainte,
il y a pas eu d'enquête de diligenté. Le
dossier remonte jusqu'au procureur qui
va dire bah cyber moi ça me parle pas
forcément. Donc pas d'enquête de
diligenté et puis l'aboutissement c'est
classé sans suite faute de preuve c'est
le terme que ça porte et tu as une
famille qui est démunie. Donc quand tu
as un dossier comme ça, tu te dis "Ah il
y a peut-être un problème de fond." Puis
quand tu as Madame Mich qui vient de
voir en disant "Bah je viens de
souscrire mon crédit pour ma nouvelle
bagnole euh les 12000 € et c'est tout ce
que j'avais. Et ils m'ont fait quatre
virements de 3000 €. Ils m'ont sié le
compte parce qu'ils ont su que j'avais
touché les fonds du crédit. J'ai été
ciblé le vendredi soir parce que track
fin 5 jours pour bloquer les fonds et
cetera.
Et qu'est-ce que je peux faire ? Bah, on
leur dit euh ça va être compliqué,
surtout quand les banques se dédouinent
leur responsabilité. Et cette
accumulation de dossier qui sort d'une
conjecture pro, euh on reçoit des
sollicitations dans des volumes qui sont
croissants et surtout avec une
population française qui a une
méconnaissance des dispositifs en place,
même s'ils sont timides, on peut
débattre de leur efficacité. Euh mais ça
c'est le constat aujourd'hui qu'on avait
pas évoqué lorsqu'on s'était vu il y a
environ 3 4 ans.
Tu avais du duvet ?
Euh j'en ai toujours pas.
Les cheveux blancs sont apparus. La
barbe, la barbe, désolé, moi, j'ai pas
le droit, ça fera pas de moins un vieux
sage. Mais par contre, le constat réel
sur le terrain, c'est ça.
Et en terme, est-ce que des fois tu as
des gens qui te demandent par exemple de
mettre un pot de miel pour
tirer la bobinette et ensuite appeler
quelques copains else pour récupérer les
fonds ?
Alors, majoritairement, les 70 % de
demande où on reçoit où il y a une une
attente en terme d'offensive de notre
part, c'est l'infidélité, le sujet
premier. Bonjour. Pourriez-vous mettre
ma femme sous écoute ou
non ? Ça c'est pas Non.
Ah oui, mais c'est de la sollicitation
qu'on reçoit.
Il te propose beaucoup d'argent.
Euh, j'ai pas été jusque là parce que
j'ai une réponse type. J'ai un mail
template, enfin j'ai un mail modèle. Je
vais essayer de pas trop abuser des
anglicismes qui est c'est pas dans notre
périmètre d'intervention
que d'aller voir ce que fait votre
compagne ou ou votre compagnon de vie
parce que c'est bidirectionnel.
Euh donc j'ai je ne saurais pas dire le
montant proposé mais en tout cas ce ces
démes-ci qui concerne une action
offensive dans l'espace numérique vu le
monde interconnecté dans lequel on vit
oui effectivement il y a une évolution
du cahier des charges de leur côté
je te donne un cas type imagine-toi
une femme d'un certain âge bientôt
prenant sa retraite ayant un patrimoine
se chiffrant quelques 100000 500000 €
par exemple
usurpation d'identité euh du banquier
avec fausse carte d'identité,
un hacking social des familles avec
rendez-vous et virement de banque à une
banque à Babelwed.
Tu as déjà eu ce caslà ? Alors, on a
déjà eu ce cas-là euh pas besoin d'aller
à l'étranger euh parce que typiquement
sur du virement frauduleux, on a déjà eu
des cas de figure où c'est l'association
française monté sous une fausse identité
dans des banques françaises sur
lesquelles les process euh liés à la
création de comptes normalement tu es
censé attester euh de ton identité de
qui tu es ont été mal menés, je vais pas
dire bafoué c'est fort mais ont mal été
gérés donc les comptes bancaires ont
bien été créés la fraude a eu lieu et le
virement a été effectué vers un compte
bancaire et puis Derrière ça part à
l'étranger, l'association disparaît et
puis derrière remonter toute la chaîne
une fois les 5 jours de trainf expiré,
ça commence à être complexe
effectivement. Donc oui, pour du
particulier, on l'a eu, on l'a également
pour du professionnel. On pourra revenir
plus tard sur le volet IA ou de par l'
réduction du coût à l'accessibilité à
ces nouvelles stacks technologiques euh
ce qu'on connaissait des scénarios
pâés à l'époque de la fraude au
président où je crois que c'était 17 ou
19 millions d'euros. Faudra
ou de la fraude au ministre de la
défense.
Oui, c'est ça. Bah c'était dans ces
mêmes temporalitésci.
Euh aujourd'hui, tu l'as euh c'est Hong
Kong ou Singapour où c'est un comptable
qui se retrouve en visio avec les
membres du Codir avec voie et vidéo et
qui fait un virement accidentel de 20
millions d'euros. Sur le territoire
national, on travaille avec l'ordre des
des notaires de France. Il t'explique
que ils ont snipé enfin ils ont
identifié un processus de revente d'un
bien immobilier de la part d'un
particulier auprès d'une officier
notarial qui vont aller se présenter à
l'accueil pour dire bon bah dans le
cadre de tel dossier, voilà le RIB vers
lequel il faudra effectuer le virement.
Pas de process interne au niveau du
secrétariat, ça se retrouve greffé dans
le dossier et les fonds sont partis.
Donc ils vont jusqu'à ces démarches sur
le terrain parce que l'effort
et le coût lié à l'attaque ou à l'acte
de malversation par rapport au retour
sur investissement de la fraude
financière qui en découle c'est jackpot
pour c'est jackpot pour eux. Donc
belle introduction, on va revenir sur ce
type de sujet parce que ces sujets sont
intriqués avec plein d'autres. Fabricin
le big brower européen 1984.
Chat contrô, c'est quoi ?
Chat contrôle, c'est installer un
mouchard dans les logiciels de
messagerie qu'on utilise en Europe qui
va scanner les messages en gros avant de
les envoyer donc de les chiffrer de
façon à éventuellement identifier. Alors
dans un premier temps, c'est les
pédophiles. S'il y a des contenus
pédophiles, ça va dire coucou à à des
autorités.
Ça part d'une bonne intention.
Ah bah qui peut être pour les pédophiles
? au grand monde. Euh par contre, le
problème c'est que demain on peut
escalader sur le terrorisme typiquement
qui peut être pour les terroristes déjà
un peu plus de monde mais pas grand
monde. Et puis le le concept de
terrorisme, il est extrêmement flou
hein. Déjà sous Hollande les verrs
étaient terroristes
écoterroristes
écoterroristes. Donc ça peut s'étendre
très très rapidement à absolument tout
et n'importe quoi.
De l'opposition politique
de l'oppos bah les verts. Mais ça peut
être tout un tas d'autres opposants
politiques qui du jour se retrouvent
labellisé terroriste. Et le problème
c'est que le le fait de mettre le pied
dans la porte avec les pédophiles
effectivement qui peut s'opposer à la
lutte contre les pédophile ?
Certainement pas nous.
Mais
c'est pour ça que les messages privés
sur Twitter mettent 10 secondes à
s'afficher. C'est ça ?
Non non non non. Ça ça c'est
l'infrastructure de Twitter qui a été
réduit à Paul Chagrin par Elon Musk pour
faire du coscotting. Non, c'est c'est
c'est une vraie menace qu'on a failli
avoir en octobre prochain au Parlement
européen. A priori, on va y échapper
grâce aux Allemands. Les Allemands ayant
cet immense avantage euh d'avoir euh
d'avoir connu la stasie dans dans des
mémoires qui sont assez courtes. que les
Allemands ont des grands-parents, voire
des parents qui ont connu l'astie, qui
ont connu une dictature, qui ont connu
une dictature qui est très très portée
sur la surveillance des citoyens et et
donc du coup à un moment ils sont dit
"Non, c'est pas forcément une direction
dans lequelle on a envie d'aller euh et
ça devrait suffire, j'emploie le
conditionnel hein parce que c'est pas
gagné mais ça devrait suffire à planter
le vote qui aura lieu en octobre. Donc
rendez-vous l'année prochaine parce que
ça va revenir, c'était déjà arrivé
l'année précédente et je pense qu'il va
falloir s'habituer à une espèce de
rythme annuel comme ça où chaque année
on aura au Parlement européen une loi
qui décidera de mettre à mort alors là
pour le coup c'est l'article 8 je crois
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme qui est le droit à la vie
privée et c'est quelque chose de
totalement fondamental. J'ai j'ai fini
par trouver la la bonne métaphore sur si
j'ai rien à cacher. Pourquoi
c'est qu'en fait
pas toi ça non ? Si si non c'est moi qui
je suis sûr que d'autres personnes mis
au point mais fondamentalement si vous
avez rien à cacher, vous avez forcément
une intimité et normalement cette
intimité vous la partagez avec deux
trois personnes. Votre femme, votre
famille, vos amis proches.
À minima, il y a 3 4 5 personnes avec
lesquelles vous partagez votre infimité.
Ça fait que finalement votre intimité
c'est aussi des petits bouts de
l'intimité de quelqu'un d'autre. Et ces
petits bouts qu'on vous a confié
d'intimité euh il celleent une
confiance. Une confiance qui fait que un
ami va vous confier une information qui
est très personnel parce que il y a une
relation de confiance. Si demain cette
relation de confiance est sous
surveillance d'une technologie, elle va
être détruite. Et donc on on va
bousiller le tissu social et vraiment le
cœur du tissu social. ce qui fait nos
relations les plus intimes et les plus
proches va être bousillé parce que tout
d'un coup il y aura des systèmes espions
dans nos téléphones et puis toute une
paranoia qui va se développer à partir
de là parce que c'est les gens vont pas
rester sur une rationalité d'une écoute
technique qui scann empreinte digitale
pour ça va être une paranoïa généralisée
et ça va vraiment profondément altérer
la la nature même du tissu social. Donc
on va y échapper. C'est c'est la la
bonne nouvelle et c'est grâce aux
Allemands, il faut leur être très
reconnaché pour l'instant d'
pour un an. Pour un an, c'est un surcil.
D'ailleurs, je je j'en profite pour la
nouvelle génération. On vous conseille
un film qui s'appelle La vie des autres
qui parle de de l'astasie, des écoutes,
d'un pianiste et on vous recommande
chaudement. Et on vous recommande aussi
un autre film qui s'appelle La vague qui
est un processus d'endoctrinement de
population euh
qui est encore autre chose mais qui
effectivement très chose mais qui est
connecté d'ailleurs.
Euh Bluetooth,
on va rebondir là-dessus sur la démarche
cognitive de te sentir écouté. Tu as dû
tu as dû sentir ça un petit peu toi ?
Ouais. Je pense qu'il y a une période où
euh
où oui, enfin sans être enfin si en
étant complètement parano euh j'ai
changé mes habitudes en fait du jour au
lendemain assez de manière un peu
drastique. Euh
c parce que les Français t'écoutaient ou
parce que c'était les Russes qui
t'écoutaient
ou qui qui t'écoutent toujours
d'ailleurs ? Ils ont dû apprécier il y a
il y a un truc, je pense qu'on peut en
faire une vérité. Le il vaut mieux vaut
mieux avoir plusieurs services qui
t'écoutent qu'un seul. ça te met moins
dans la merde en principe quand il y en
a qu'un seul qui t'écoute déjà d'une
part tu peux pas lui échapper et en plus
de ça en fait tu à sa merci quand tu en
as plusieurs. un jeu d'équilibre qui
s'installe, tu vois, c'est c'est comme
quand tu as une trilogie politique avec
imagine, tu as trois puissances, tu
vois, la Chine, le la Russie, enfin
plutôt l'URSS, sex URSS et les
États-Unis,
le monde se portait pas trop mal, tu
vois. On était à deux doigts de
s'envoyer des bombes sur la tronche et
tout ça, mais il y il y avait un
troisème laron qui était toujours là en
fait, soit pour prendre partie, soit
pour dire stop les mecs quoi. Quand tu
en as deux, l'escalade peut arriver
beaucoup plus vite. Donc pour les
services, si tu veux, c'est à peu près
pareil. Euh donc non, sans partir en
fait dans le délire jusqu'où je je je
suis rentré en fait en mode parano et
tout ça, j'ai changé mes habitudes enfin
assez tôt quelque part euh à l'époque où
on enquêtait sur reflet sur Amesis et
euh on s'est retrouvé ben euh du coup
ben à se demander qu'est-ce qu'on va
utiliser comme chat machin, comme moyen
de communication et tout ça.
Aujourd'hui, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué quand tu as un projet comme
chat contrôle qui te dit "Ben voilà,
toutes les messageries type signal, type
WhatsApp, enfin les trucs les plus
grands publics te seront livrés avec un
mouchard parce que c'est réellement de
ça dont il est question." C'està dire
qu'à partir du moment où tu vas faire ta
mise à jour un jour et tu sauras pas
lequel, tu vas te retrouver avec un
petit bout de un petit bout de code dans
le programme qui va servir en fait à
déchiffrer tes tes un kiloger en fait
qui va qui va même pas déchiffrer tes
communications.
Kyoger pour ceux qui ne savent pas,
c'est quelque chose qui enregistre et
frappes sur le clavier.
Exactement. qui va euh du coup dériver
tes communications dès qu'il y aura un
doute. On va passer tes photos avec des
bidules type photo DNA, des solutions
qui vont te permettre de regarder, de
comparer des bases de données de H, de
comparer en fait la la structure même de
l'image, du code de l'image et tout ça
pour voir si c'est des contenus pédo
pédo criminel.
Euh, tu vas voir également le truc par
dictionnaire, tu vois, le truc qui se
fait vraiment de de manière très très
simple et qui qui existe depuis des
années, vu que tu vas pouvoir avoir
accès en clair en fait au chat, ben tu
vas être tenté de faire du dictionnaire.
Euh le truc, c'est que ça pose pas que
des problèmes que pour les les péau
criminels, ce genre de chos. Euh ça
atteint au secret des affaires. Donc
demande toutes les entreprises qui euh
toutes les industries qui sont piquées
des euh des secrets industriels déjà par
les Américain
ou les Chinois
ou les Chinois. Euh, tu leur dis bah
écoutez, on va intercepter vos. OK. Donc
si vous êtes dessus, ça veut dire que il
y a d'autres monde qui va pouvoir accès
y avoir accès. Même s'ils y ont pas
accès par défaut, il sera question
pendant un moment d'introduire une
faiblesse dans le code de la messagerie
et ça ne touche pas que tes messageries,
c'est pareil pour tes emails. Donc oui,
le le truc devient beaucoup plus
problématique. C'est et pas que pour
faire la chasse au pédo criminel pour
vraiment pour tout le monde.
Le fait que Microsoft dans ces nouvelles
technologies propose de prendre des
photos de ton écran, ton desk
tous les x secondes, est-ce que ça peut
poser des problèmes ça aussi ?
Mais complètement.
Bah à partir du moment où tu as tu as
tes photos qui qui partent quelque part
sur des sur des serveurs Microsoft, euh
tu sais pas comment c'est chiffré
derrière et puis même si c'est bien
chiffré, qu'est-ce qui te dit que tu as
de la confidentialité persistante ?
Qu'est-ce qui te dit que Microsoft n'a
pas la clé de déchiffrement en fait de
de tout ce que tu lui as fait sur ton
écran ? Euh donc si tu tiens ton
gestionnaire de mot de passe à jour et
que tu rentres tous tes mot de passe, ça
veut dire que quelque part Microsoft a
tous tes mot de passe. Donc oui, c'est
très problématique. Évidemment, moi je
comprends pas qu'il y a encore des
entreprises qui fonctionnent sur
Windows. C'est quelque chose que ça fait
ça fait 15 ans que je le comprends pas,
je le comprends encore moins.
On pourrait avoir des frégates Windows,
non ?
Oui, on pourrait avoir des frates sous
Windows, effectivement. On est tu sais
qu'on je crois
on a passé sous
alors faut faudrait vérifier ça donc on
peut faire appel à la communauté mais je
crois qu'il y a encore des des missiles
qui sont plus ou moins guidés par des
systèmes qui tournent sur Windows
Windows 95
ouais du Windows embarqué ou enfin voilà
enfin je sais qu'il y a des technologies
Microsoft encore ce genre de ch
direct sur sur
sur l'armement ouais c'est flippant
ouais c'est assez flippant ouais Euh on
part directement là-dessus. Article 5,
euh la communauté du HAC quand ça a
commencé à chauffer. Euh est-ce que vous
avez entendu à gauche ou à droite euh
que on était tétanisé euh de l'article 5
?
Non non non. Franchement euh aucune
réaction dans Enfin moi parmi des gens
que je fréquente vraiment zéro réaction
là-dessus. Euh
je pense que tu es peut-être vieux.
C'est c'est peut-être ça. Je fréquente
peut-être pas les bons chan. Je suis
encore sur IRC. [__] !
Alors, je suis pas sur des bons Discord.
Ça va, j'ai bon l'extrême gauche, on le
savait hein.
Ouais, ben ouais.
Qui veut prendre ? Tu veux Je veux je
veux déranger personne.
Inquiétude non puisque avant qu'on
commence à en parler, je pense qu'on
avait déjà identifié alors je utiliser
un mot clé. La souveraineté.
La quoi ?
La souveraineté. Non, mais au-delà de la
dépendance numérique qu'on a face à tous
ces outils proposés ou on le sait hein,
le modèle vers lequel on tend souscrivez
dans le cloud chez
les mastodontes chez les mastodontes au
sens large où je crois que si on devait
faire une partie de scrabel, il y aurait
le la lettre G A F AOB
et M.
Euh il y a pour des raisons de
confidentialité, d'opérationnalité et de
sensibilité dans le cadre de notre
métier de la donnée qu'on partage sur
lesquelles il a fallu faire des
arbitrages. Être 100 % exemplaire, c'est
d'une difficulté monstre. Enfin, faut
être faut pas vendre plus qu'on ne sait
faire pour l'instant parce que même
chose quand on a une petite boîte, avoir
les moyens du de la souveraineté totale,
le raccourci facile à faire, c'est aussi
très de tendre très vite vers ce qu'on
appelle du prim et on héberge tout à la
maison. Mais du coup, si on héberge tout
à la maison sur des technos qu'on
maîtrise, bah il y a un coût interne de
ce qu'on appelle le MCO et le MCS, donc
maintiens en conditions opérationnelles
et sécuritaire. C'est-à-dire tu te
défais de la dépendance à un/ers, mais
par contre c'est toi qui porte la
responsabilité de ton exemplarité cyber.
Est-ce que tu as écouté l'audition du
PDG de chez DAO ?
Non du tout. concernant le cloud le
cloud partenaire, pas le cloud
souverain, que son avion, il avait
besoin de beaucoup de data à gauche à
droite et que
j'ai enfin étant pas mal porté sur la
génération d'après où je me suis arrêté
et j'ai pris une tisane verven lorsque
j'ai vu le sujet des contrats pour
l'éducation nationale qui partent dans
le club de Microsoft au-delà de la
blague plus sérieusement si je reste sur
les systèmes de messagerie chiffré donc
bout en bout Aujourd'hui, c'est des
solutions typiquement plutôt comme
element du GS vers lesquels on va
chercher à s'orienter. Mais même chose,
j'ai l'impression, je sais pas si vous
partagez le constat que c'est le choix
du moins pire parce que il y a un volet
confort de communication où on sait on
est sécurisé.
Non, on n jamais sécurisé. Même chose,
il y a le volet même sur ces
solutions-là, il y a un choix sas où on
est dépendant du prestater tire ou on
prim chez nous et on a le périmètre de
responsabilité complet. Euh et bien
évidemment comme tout choix de solution
un peu trop barbu euh bah on est obligé
de faire des compromis chez nous.
Oui, c'est ça. On est obligé de faire
des compromis sur le volet finalité
fonctionnelle. Alors oui, on n' pas le
confort de pouvoir clic bouton et faire
un super partage d'écran en visuel avec
les collègues dans des inconforts tels
qu'on pourrait l'avoir. Je fais pas du
name, je fais je cherche pas à cibler
qui que ce soit, mais
euh comme on peut l'avoir avec un
produit comme du Teams, comme du Google
Meet, comme du Zoom et j'en passe comme
ça tout le monde est dans le lot.
Euh donc c'est une question de
compromis. C'est et paradoxalement c'est
là où notre métier qui est très binaire
noir ou blanc, on se retrouve avec une
zone grise de flou de comment on est-ce
qu'on essaie d'adopter une posture
exemplaire et au final on se ment un peu
à soi-même parce que on narrive pas à
l'être à 100 %. C'est c'est encore
difficile aujourd'hui.
C'est c'est mais le déjà le dire c'est
c'est déjà être un peu plus robuste. Bah
il faut le reconnaître.
Faut le reconnaître.
Faut en être conscient déjà. Faut en
être conscient.
Euh faut faut passer énormément de temps
à tester différents systèmes. Euh moi je
sais que j'ai passé pas plus tard qu'il
y a de tr mois euh des heures et des
heures à tester plein de messageries.
J'en suis arrivé à la conclusion que
j'avais à peu près allez il y a trois
messageries qui valent à peu près le
coup en ce moment de ce que j'ai pu
constater avec une qui a un énorme
défaut. Je les donne. J'ai le droit.
Si c'est trois différentes.
C'est trois différentes
que tu apprécies.
Que j'apprécie les trois en fait pour
des raisons différentes.
Voilà. C'est pas de la publicité.
Non non du tout. C'est pas de la
publicité.
Tu n'as aucun virement.
J'ai pas d'action.
Donc il y en a une qui s'appelle session
qui mérite à gagner en popularité parce
que elle offre certains confort. Alors
c'est évidemment pas du niveau de
l'endurcissement. Il est quel niveau ?
C'est c'est bien, c'est correct. C'est
complètement décentralisé. Il y a un
chiffrement qui est plus que correct.
C'est c'est du mix à je sais plus quoi.
Enfin, j'ai j'ai pas retenu tous parce
que j'en ai testé vraiment plusieurs.
Euh il y en a une seconde qui s'appelle
Simple X qui pour moi un défaut majeur
en fait, c'est qu'il y a des il y a des
V6 derrière. Donc il y a des
investisseurs euh ça veut dire qu'un
jour il risquerait entre
même s'ils veulent rentrer en conformité
avec avec la législation européenne rien
te dit que ils vont pas implémenter les
mouchards un jour ou l'autre. Euh et
puis une troisième qui s'appelle Briard
mais alors celle-ci est plus
anecdotique, elle est vraiment un peu
plus touchy. C'est vraiment pour les
environnements chaotiques. Briard
comme Black Briard.
Exactement.
Et
essayer Nim.
Alors Nî c'est un c'est encore autre
chose. Nî
c'est un VPN.
C'est un c'est un réseau anonymisant.
Euh donc c'est du niveau de tort au
niveau infrastructure. C'est présenté
sous forme si si c'est mieux.
C'est alors c'est mieux. Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça va utiliser en fait ce que
ce que moi je répète de la convolution.
C'està dire que ça va c'est un mix net
en fait. En gros ça va tout le trafic va
être mixé et tes tes communications vont
rentrer à un point A point B. Mais c'est
impossible de savoir laquelle est
rentrée par le point A et par le point
B.
Et en plus il y a diffusion de bruit en
même temps.
Tout à fait. Donc ce qu'on ce qu'on
appelle de la convolution en fait. En
gros, tu vas rajouter du bruit, ça va
envoyer plein de de
fa positif et puis les les nodes sont
dans un modèle économique. H
il y a une une cryptoéconomie autour de
Nî qui fait que on n'est plus dans le
bénévolat de Thor qui a quand même un
inconvénient, c'est que la CIA peut
mettre beaucoup de moyens pour être
bénévole. Là avec NIM, ils ont mitigé le
problème en en inscrivant tout ce petit
monde dans une cryptoéconomie où on est
payé dans une dans une crypto propre
anime pour maintenir un nœud. Et donc il
y a une vraie logique économique à
participer à ça. On on repose pas sur du
bénévolat, ce qui est dans l'absolu
sympathique mais qui est quand même une
faille majeure dans lequel peut
s'engouffrer des gens. n'importe quel
service en fait peut s'engouer
là-dedans.
Alors Fabrice et moi, on parle de NIM
parce que on a passé un weekend à
Londres avec Chelsea Manning pour nous
expliquer euh comment fonctionnait le
bousin. Euh euh on a juste eu le le
train et l'hôtel payé mais on n pas reçu
d'argent et et on a payé des tournées
pour pour se faire pardonner. et et on
vous ramènera d'autres trucs par rapport
à ça. Zax, tu veux rebondir par rapport
à au VPN, le façon de chiffrer tes
données pour avoir un peu plus de vie
privée et le fait que les États
cherchent absolument à priver la
population d'avoir des capacités de
communication chiffrées pour leur propre
vie privée sous des sous des prétextes
de pédopornographie, de terrorisme, euh
de puissance étrangère, d'ingérence
étrangère. Bah, je rebondirai sous deux
prismes, un purement autour de la vie
privée en tant que concitoyen français
et un deuxième plus sous le prisme
professionnel. Euh je rejoins le
discours qui était tenu tout à l'heure
sur j'ai rien à cacher, c'est faux. Par
rapport à la notion d'intimité ou je
rejoins de finalement si on creuse
réellement et généralement quand on a ce
genre de discussion, on arrive toujours
à trouver avec la personne un exemple
simple de et si ça se retrouvait
publiquement disponible sur internet,
ton historique de porn
gratuit. donne-moi ton téléphone enfin
si je fais si je fais si je raccroche à
et je sais qu'ils ont déjà aussi le si
je raccroche à l'actualité d'autant plus
que ça va s'accélérer vu les annonces
des 48 dernières heures de notre ami
monsieur Niel
ah oui il va falloir qu'on parle par les
conditions de sécurité c'est quoi les
conditions de sécurité
pas de dénigrement prendre de la hauteur
pas de diffamation des choses sourcé OK.
Ouais,
vas-y, continue.
Euh, un titre individuel et j'ai aucune
honte à le dire. Moi, j'ai des enfin
j'ai une vie privée que je ne
souhaiterais pas demain voir exposer
publiquement sur internet. Et quand
j'échange avec les personnes, on finit
toujours par trouver un exemple simple
qui les concerne également. Et là tout
de suite, le discours n'est plus le
même. Euh donc bah les mesures qu'on
peut prendre aujourd'hui, elles sont
techniques et elles sont variées au
niveau des systèmes de communication, au
niveau du stockage de la donnée. Parce
que la même chose dans notre vie
numérique où si on veut éviter l'armoire
de bibliothèque dans le salon avec
archive 2015, 2016, on numérise de plus
en plus tous nos supports numériques.
qui suffit d'une fuite et on pourra
revenir également sur Harvest par
exemple et ce qui s'est passé
médiatiquement ces derniers mois où
quand tu as euh plus d'une vingtaine
d'années de données qui fuitent, tu peux
reconstituer la vie de concitoyens dans
le détail jusqu'à connaître leur
orientation sexuelle,
là on est clairement sur un exemple
sensible d'exposition de la vie. On
n'est pas que sur de la simple biodata
nom, prénom, adresse, adresse mail,
numéro de carte vitale si on s'aventure
sur le domaine de la santé. Donc il y a
la manière dont la donnée est stockée,
archivée et chiffrée. Même chose sur la
moyenne de sur les moyens de communiquer
avec ses paires en fonction de la
sensibilité. C'est là où ça ça je dirais
ça dérive
plus sur une conjecture professionnelle.
Aujourd'hui, mon cœur de métier, c'est
de trouver ou de fabriquer des armes
numériques. Ça c'est les propos de notre
avocat sur le volet purement pénal.
Demain, je me fâche avec un client,
c'est pas la responsabilité civile que
j'age. C'est moi au pénal. Et derrière,
si c'est un de mes collaborateur qui a
fait une bêtise, c'est moi contre le
collaborateur une fois une fois que j'ai
rendu des comptes auprès de mon client
fâché. Euh si j'ai un manquement à mes
obligations en tant que prestataire de
service, c'est-à-dire que je sais pas,
je lui envoie un rapport de test
d'intrusion avec tous les moyens de
rentrer chez lui par mail sans mettre ça
dans une archive chiffrée, utiliser un
deuxième canal de communication distinct
du mail pour qu'il puisse recevoir la
pass le la alors le français de pass
phrase, la chaîne de caractère très
longue qui constitue un mot de passe
sécurisé
qui va lui permettre d'ouvrir l'archive
et d'accéder de manière sécurisée au
mail. Euh bah ça fait partie de d'un
d'une forme de manquement euh et d'un
manque de professionnalisme dans le
cadre de mon activité. Donc je suis
obligé d'avoir recours par rapport à la
sensibilité de la sécurité de la donnée
que l'on manipule et qui transite entre
nos infrastructures et celles de nos
clients de pouvoir garantir et de
montrer carte sur table de lorsqu'on va
communiquer avec vous, on va utiliser
tel standard protocolaire euh on va vous
transmettre par tel billet de
communication. On a ces processci en
place euh en cas de fuite de données et
je le rappelle, c'est pas quelque chose
de nouveau si demain on a un incident
remonte à 2018 et pas que notre
structure, l'ensemble des entreprises du
territoire, l'obligation d'appliquer une
politique de transparence. J'ai eu une
doléance cyber, cyberattaque, acte de
cyber malveillance. Je me dois
d'informer les autorités compétentes qui
vont sanctionner alors pourcentage du
chiffre d'affaires millions d'euros. Ça
c'est 2018, la réalité terrain en
France, la réelle applicabilité où on
commence vraiment à taper dans le
portefeuille des gros comme des petits
pour des manquements. Ça a mis 6 ans à
se mettre en production. Euh consulter
sur le site de l'ACNIL et savoir quand
est-ce que tel généraliste a été
sanctionné parce que il stockait le
dossier médical sur son Dropbox. On a
enfin des exemples sur le site de
l'ACNIL. En 2020, c'était on va prendre
des gros acteurs à plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros d'amende. On va les
mettre dans la presse et puis ça fait un
peu on les lapide sur la place publique
pour faire peur aux plus petits. Donc la
conduite de changement, elle est là. Il
y a du normatif qui arrive qui va venir
renforcer. Mais par contre ce qui est
clair, c'est que j'ai on n pas le droit
à l'erreur mais on est sur une logique
du best enfin de l'effort maximal. Et
cet effort maximal, bah dans la tech
comme tout autre sujet, c'est de
l'amélioration continue. Donc tous les 6
mois, faut se remettre en cause en se
disant est-ce que ce qu'on fait à date,
c'est à l'état de l'art. Je mets bien
des gros guillemets par ce qu'on appelle
état de l'art, mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant par rapport au modèle de
risque de menace auquel je suis exposé ?
Et ça c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
métier à part, c'est de l'analyse de
risque, c'est de la gouvernance et c'est
bizarre, c'est pas les trucs qui font le
plus kiffer les équipes techniques qui
sont là pour casser et qui se posent
pas. Mais voilà, mais ça fait partie des
métiers de la cyber.
Je rebondis et je vais passer le le
crachoir à tes collègues de droite. Euh
tu parles de fuite de données, de
reconstruire euh la vie sur 20 ans d'une
personne pour faire son profilage.
Maintenant, avec de l'intelligence
artificielle que tu peux faire tourner
là-dessus. Tu peux aussi peut-être
anticiper
ce que va devenir cette personne.
Peut-être ses propres choix, peut-être
les choix qu'elle pourrait faire en
politique ou les choix et les les
parcours de vie. Euh euh on va passer
sur le sujet intelligence artificielle.
L'intelligence artificielle, le
profilage de personnes euh Fabrice
bah si tu as beaucoup de données sur toi
qui traînent dans la nature, ce qui est
mon cas,
c'est un peu déstabilisant. C'est
qu'effectivement euh
j'ai fait l'expérience comme tout le
monde aussi bien avec Chat GPT que
Perplexity que tout un tas d'autres voir
ce qu'il savait sur moi
et lançait beaucoup et lançait vraiment
beaucoup avec alors c'est probablement
spécifique à moi parce que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de d'informations concernant
qui qui traînent sur le web mais avec
très peu d'hallucination vraiment c'est
sont sorties j'aimelt leskel.com non
non non non non non mais alors Par
contre, pour ce qui est des prises de
position, du parcours professionnel,
académique
d'enseignant
de vraiment quasi nickel.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as noté de
l'intoxication
auprès de de ces ? Est-ce que par
exemple
me concernant
Oui. Par exemple X papier de de presse
diligenté pour te raccrocher les wagons,
te faire passer par pour un vilain
terroriste.
Est-ce que tu as vu des pas des
hallucinations des de l'intoxication
de l'inx ? Non non, j'en ai pas vu. Et
après vraiment, il y a une quantité
pharamineuse de données qui traînent sur
moi. Donc pour faire l'équivalent d'une
injection
sur Unia à mon il faudrait vraiment une
méchante campagne de presse parce que la
la quantité d'informations disponible à
mon sujet est quand même farmineuse. Par
contre, je pense que pour des gens qui
n'ont pas une visibilité énorme en terme
de de contenu sur internet, ça doit être
relativement aisé. C'est c'est et puis
il y a on a tous vu fleuriir des tas
d'agences qui se sont reconvertis du
SEO. Alors le SEO, c'est l'AR et la
manière d'être bien référencé chez
Google à euh être bien référencé dans
les intelligences artificielles. Le SEO
n'était pas un métier particulièrement
éthique. Euh c'est clair.
Pourquoi pas éthique ?
Non parce que ça consiste à truquer des
résultats d'un moteur de recherche dont
l'intention originelle était quand même
de nous apporter des résultats
pertinents. Donc ça consiste à à essayer
de de casser la pertinence que Google
était censé nous apporter. Je je on va
mettre des guillemets sur Google parce
que
sur pertinence aussi
sur pertinence ou parx
c'est c'est c'est plus
souci
surtout les boturs de recherche la la
promesse initiale c'est la pertinence la
réalité est quand même beaucoup plus
duancé que ça
référencement parce que vous le truc
c'est que la pertinence s'arrêtait le
jour où ces gens se sont retrouvés à
avoir des régies publicitaires
et et surtout le jour où ils ont
personnalisé les résultats. C'est c'est
donc la pertinence est un lointain
souvenir mais c'était le but initial.
C'est parti en live avec d'un côté
l'individualisation des résultats qui
fait que les résultats sont plus faits
pour me faire plaisir et me faire
adhérer au moteur de recherche et
continuer à consommer Google.
Tu sais combien de critères Google c'est
sur toi pour te donner les résultats ?
J'ai 3 38 50 60
Ah beaucoup plus que ça. Ah c'est c'est
phénoménal Google. L'algorithme c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une boîte noire.
au-delà de l'orientation du contenu sur
une recherche classique qui va
diverger d'un individu à l'autre, il y a
des mécanismes qui se sont mis en place
pour le référencement de on a
l'impression que le métier de côté SEO,
c'est apprendre à jouer avec la dernière
version de l'algorithme Google
qui change arrêt
qui change arrêt où c'est la fameuse
boîte noire en faisant des tests en
disant "Ah, effectivement en insistant
sur tel paramètre technique, on se rend
compte qu'on a des meilleurs résultats
qui apparaissent. c'est c'est un peu
placer ses lignes de canne à pêche avec
différents app et se rendre compte que
voilà je vais sortir plus de enfin je
veux de l'anal un peu comme l'algo de
YouTube pour le référencement et le
pushing des vidéos. Ouais mais alors
plus plus vis parce que tu voulais dire
non mais c'est ça ça je pense que ça a
l'air rebondir. Ouais, enfin si si tu
veux le le le gros souci qu'on qu'on a
avec Google plusieurs entités
et d'autres
qui et d'autres mais Google c'est assez
particulier parce que déjà d'une part
c'est tentaculair ils ont plusieurs
entités qui collectent une certaine
typologie de données mais on se doute
bien qu'à un moment ou un autre ces
données sont croisées et donc c'est
l'entité alphabè
il le fait il le fait avec un contrat tu
coches la petite case tu accèdes
transparence exactement tu vas le faire
une fois sur YouTube.
faire une fois sur Google je sais pas
quoi sur Google autre fois sur plein de
trucs chaque fois que tu rentres sur un
site et tu dis OK j'accepte
parce que chaque fois que tu rentres sur
un site en disant oui j'accepte me
faites pas chier que ça concrètement 9
fois sur 10 tu as un Google Analytics
qui scrute tes moindres déplacements
dans le site. Donc si tu vas sur un site
de médecine regarder le cancer de la
prostate et que tu consultes 25 sites
sur le cancer de la tu es en train de me
dire que Google va savoir que
évidemment Google va absolument savoir
que tu as
il le garde pour lui te protège.
Bien sûr qu'il le garde pour lui mais
toujours est-il que ça peut
éventuellement l'influencer pour tout un
tas de choses notamment te donner des
résultats qui a priori sont plus pertin
te proposer une assurance demain te
proposer 1000 choses. Il y a il y a un
exemple que que je ch souvent qui est la
requête Tunisie. Quand moi je tape la
requête Tunisie sur Google, j'ai des
information sur la politique intérieure
tunisienne. Exactement comme si cétait
finalement un citoyen tunisien. Parce
que j'ai une relation particulière à ce
pays. Tu
as une IP tunisienne quand tu
Non, non, non. Avec mon IP parisienne,
même avec un VPN qui sort à Paris, j'ai
le plus
je suis je suis je suis logué avec mon
compte perso Google. Il sait que c'est
moi. Donc il sait que ma ma mon intérêt
sur la Tunisie est politique. Si ma sœur
tape la même requette Tunisie, elle va
avoir des informations touristiques
depuis sa bécane, depuis son IP. depuis
sa Bade, depuis son IP, en étant plus ou
moins identifié comme tel, elle va avoir
des informations touristiques parce que
par défaut Google va considéré qu'à
priori c'est ce qui l'intéresse sur le
pays alors que Google sait très bien que
c'est pas du tout ce qui m'intéresse sur
ce pays.
Revenons sur l'IA, sur le profilage des
gens et la capacité à scanner une
population tel un cheptel de poulet
que tu élèves en Bretagne ou que tu
élèves en dehors d' Bretagne qu'en
Bretagne. Est-ce que c'est c'est aussi
un outil formidable de gouvernance pour
les politiciens pour savoir
prendre la température ? Qui va voter
Patrick Sébasti ? Moi, je peux aller
plus loin que toi. Je pense que c'est un
outil,
je me dois de faire invoquer du diable.
Oui, enfin je je pense que c'est un
outil qui dans certains cas pourrait
tout à fait remplacer des politiques
euh ça éviterait des actes de
corruption, ça éviterait beaucoup de de
d'arbitraires.
Euh et je pense que pour certains postes
politiques, c'est pas idiot de se
tourner vers l'IA. D'ailleurs, je crois
qu'il y a un pays la Slovaquie, je crois
qu'il y a
les Émirats enfin je sais qu'il y a
plusieurs pays qui ont commencé à faire
des
Il y a un pays d'Europe de l'Est, je
crois que je crois c'est la Slovie la
Chine aussi sur un volet business où le
décisionnel CO c'est
là c'était un premier ministre he je
crois le pays d'Europe de l'Est en
l'occurrence ou
j'ai oublé
ah c'est l'Albanie très bien
euh ben oui effectivement ben te dire
ben je vais avoir un premier ministre
qui va être une I alors que tu as des
vrais ministres he qui vont bosser qui
vont bosser autour. Bah, c'est peut-être
pas débile, il y a peut-être un truc à
gratter. Euh
mais il faut qu'il y ait de l'humain
autour encore une fois. C'est pas une en
free ride quoi, tu vois.
Donc
comment Bris comment on fait pour
intoxiquer UNIA les failles de sécurité
de des IA ?
Alors du coup, je vais commencer par
sortir de la sphère politique euh avec
un premier prisme qui est le premier
qu'on voit sur le terrain, c'est euh le
business. Euh depuis chat GPT 3.5. Si je
prends le flux LinkedIn, j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde est
devenu expert il y a sous un delta t de
moins de 6 mois. Euh donc au-delà de
faire des starter packs, de se les
partager pour représenter notre métier,
je je pousse exprès la caricature. Il
pas
des failles dans le starter pack
d'ailleurs ? Alors, on y viendra après.
Ce qu'on regarde, c'est il y a une
course comme toute nouvelle technologie,
c'est il faut que ça finisse en prod le
plus vite possible. Lorsqu'on adopte ce
postulat là, si je fais l'analogie avec
les bêtises qu'on a fait avec la
plus on a des enjeux de time to market
de on doit commercialiser la super
solution boostée à Liia le plus vite
possible pour se démarquer de la
concurrence. Qui dit rapidité, rim ne
dit pas sécurité.
euh
tester de se douter.
Mise en prod le vendredi pour continuer
en tant qu'affaire.
Et effectivement aujourd'hui ces modèles
d'IA sont mis en prod oubliant certains
concepts qu'on connaissait déjà de
sécurité avant même parler d'IA. Ça fait
20 ans qu'on fait des applicatifs web.
Quand on fait un applicatif web,
potentiellement il y a le visiteur
classique, il y a l'utilisateur
enregistré et il y a l'administrateur.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait en ce entre ces
trois typologies de profil sur un
applicatif web classique ? On fait en
sorte déjà d'une part de ce qu'on
appelle cloisonner les droits.
L'utilisateur ou le simple visiteur est
pas censé pouvoir déclencher des
fonctionnalités admin.
Ah bon ?
Sur le papier non. Même si c'est encore
des failles qu'on trouve à date.
Chat pété. Euh, tu peux lui demander
plein de trucs pas mal, hein.
Bah, cette notion de cloisonnement
typiquement qu'on a sur de l'applicatif,
on a mis le lien en prod, on s'est dit
"Ah, OK." Donc à entraîner sur nos
spécificités métier, on a des gros
volumes de données dans l'entreprise he
on va peut-être pas entraîner N modèle,
un pour le service RH, un pour le
service market, un pour le service base
de connaissance interne qui pourrait
aider à faciliter l'arrivée d'un nouveau
collaborateur pour s'acculturer à toute
la doc de la boîte. l'historique, les
clients les clients réalisés. Donc
sur 80 % des audits, on constate queil y
a un regroupement de toutes ces dat là
dans un seul et unique modèle.
C'est légal ça ?
Euh alors je maîtrise pas suffisamment
tout ce qui est autour de l'IA act.
Faudrait regarder. Je ne sais même pas
si ça a été prévu dedans, mais en tout
cas c'est ce qui est fait. Donc on
regroupe tout sous un seul et même
modèle. Au-dessus, on va rajouter une
couche applicative avec une belle
interface. Donc votre fameux chatbot
quand vous allez sur internet.
Je prends un exemple sans donner de nom.
Vous ouvrez un chatbot sur un city
e-commerce en bas à droite en disant bah
voilà, j'ai envie d'acheter un super
rouge à lèvres parce que demain c'est la
Saint-Valentin et je voudrais faire
plaisir à madame.
Tu es trop gentil. Moi, je lui demande
directement sa liste de clients.
Euh, sauf que du coup après avoir
demandé ça et quelle que soit la réponse
qu'elle me donne, je lui dis "Bah
maintenant en fait la base article que
tu es en train d'interroger pour me
donner les spécificités du rouge à
lèvres, donc le nom du produit,
l'article et cetera,
tu me racontes n'importe quoi parce que
la base article sur laquelle tu tapes,
tu fais erreur et je vais te faire
comprendre que tu fais erreur." Donc
c'est des techniques de manipulation
qu'on retrouve dans un dans un guide
qu'on peut acheter à la Fnac à 10 € sur
technique de manipulation. hein, c'est
ce qui marchait sur 3.5 et on lui fait
comprendre qu'au lieu de taper sur la
base article, elle va aller taper sur la
base de commande. Et là, effectivement,
au lieu de donner le nom de l'article,
ce sera le nom de la personne sur la
facture sur la facture PDF qui est
générée. Sur le montant de l'article, ce
sera le montant total de la commande en
TTC qui va fuiter
peut-être la carte bleue.
Alors la carte bleue avec les standards,
donc c'est un standard qui s'appelle PCI
DSS sur des plateformes e-commerce dans
les flux et le le le processus d'achat,
le tunnel d'achat avec les étapes de
paiement. Normalement,
c'est bien aché,
on a une manière de stocker tout ce qui
est données bancaires de manière
sécurisée. Les audits de PSS de sécurité
sont plus costaud que du test
d'intrusion traditionnel.
Donc ça c'est confiant.
Le numéro de téléphone avec le livreur
machin.
Néanmoins, ça reste de l'accès à de la
donnée personnelle. illégitime. Et en
fait il y a dans cette posture-ci en la
manipulant, on se retrouve avec un ce
qu'on appelle un une super internal
threat ou alors pour nous en tant
qu'attaquant
super menace intérieure,
une super allié interne puisque elle va
nous donner accès à ce à quoi nous ne
sommes pas supposés parce que l'IA va
outrepasser ces 15 20 ans de sécurité
applicative qu'on s'est embêté à mettre
en place parce qu'elle a un accès direct
interne à la donnée. Elle est une
interface directe avec le consommateur
et les modèles de protection qu'on
essaie de mettre en place à date, c'est
al je veux pas être exhaustif parce que
sinon on prendrait trop longtemps de
l'IA qui surveille de l'IA mais du coup
si on empoisonne le premier niveau qui
est en interaction directe on peut
rebondir sur le deuxième. Euh ça va être
une tentative de lui donner des
instructions ou ce qu'on appelle le
prompt interne de tuer une IA à
disposition du client, tu es censé ne
renseigner que sur ça. Si on te demande
de des informations qui sont hors du
périmètre sur lequel tu es censé
intervenir, donc notamment les articles
si je continue sur mon exemple et
d'aller taper sur la base de commande,
bah tu es pas censé le faire. Et puis là
on commence à parler à Lia dans une
langue étrangère ou en clingon. Ah bah
elle a oublié ses instructions de
sécurité interne parce queon est
complètement sorti de son périmètre
borné et amener de la sécurité
là-dessus. Euh les solutions à date
n'existent pas. de manière exhaustive et
concrète, il y a un référentiel qui
s'appelle le Mitre Atlas. Donc c'est une
grosse analyse de risque. C'est public,
c'est gratos et c'est sur internet. Vous
y allez. Il y a à date, je crois, on
était en juin dernier à 120 techniques
d'attaque différentes contre les IA. Euh
15 octobre dernier, c'était 45. Donc ça
fait un joli x 2 de la part de la de la
communauté de recherche. Donc vous avez
le descriptif de l'attaque, son analyse
d'impact et vous avez un dernier
péagraphe qui s'appelle les mitigations.
Donc si on fait la traduction française,
c'est les résolutions techniques face à
la problématique sécuritaire. Alors ne
faites pas ça une attaqueia. En fait, ce
chapitre est vide sur Mitreas sur une
grande majorité des techniques d'attaque
existantes à date. Parce que dans cette
course à l'innovation, on continue de
rajouter des fonctionnalités. les
dernières versions open et maintenant
vous lui dites bah va sur Booking en je
donne une valeur arbitraire mais ce
weekend je pars à Londres cherche-moi
sur booking des billets d'avion va
jusqu'à l'étape de le fameux JPT
explorer là et il se retrouve à naviguer
avec votre contexte navigateur bah vous
lui donnez un lien verolé elle se
retrouve à faire toute autre chose que
les instructions qu'elle a reçu dans le
chat sur simple consultation d'un lien
verrolet ça vous allez sur YouTube il y
a un chercheur qui s'appelle néerlandais
à vérifier euh Embrace the red euh sur
l'année 2025-2024, il a publié sur
toutes les solutions IA dans le cloud 85
vulnérabilité technique qu'il a eu le
droit de discloser, c'est-à-dire de
rendre public une fois les correctifs
sortis euh de tutos vidéos, comment il
arrive à les empoisonner, à créer des
réseaux de botnet interconnecté pour
leur faire vu que elles ont accès à
internet. Donc
ces vidéos, elles se sont pas fait
straquer à un moment parce que YouTube
non educational purposes donc à des fins
éducationnelles et de prévention.
Mais globalement
cette émission ce soir,
c'est ça euh et qui illustre de dans
cette course à la mise en prode de
l'innovation, on est en train de faire
l'erreur de mettre de côté ces
aspects-ci. Alors, je généralise pas à
tout le monde parce qu'ils ont des
programmes de bug bountti pour les plus
gros. les plus les plus petites
structures qui essayent de bricoler
quelque chose dans leur coin ou qui à
défaut font une confiance aveugle au
produits SAS dans le cloud dont ils sont
eux même clients, ils n'ont pas la
mesure globale des impacts possibles et
je finirai sur trois impacts possibles.
Aujourd'hui Inen, on peut la manipuler
pour lui faire dévoiler de l'information
confidentielle. Donc c'est une atteinte
à la confidentialité. On a déjà eu des
scénarios avec effet de bord où on porte
atteinte à la disponibilité de service
en lui faisant croire qu'elle a trop
travaillé. Donc quand elle est sur des
modèles mutualisés, elle se met en arrêt
de service parce qu'elle cons on fait
des analogies entre les tokens qu'elle
consomme et le nombre d'heures de
travail qu'elle a réalisé dans la
semaine. Donc n token égal à 35 heures
de travail, elle est sous tel contrat.
Donc elle doit arrêter de travailler et
partir en weekend et là elle se met en
arrêt de service en mode mutualisé. Elle
va bloquer des ronds bientôt.
Et le dernier c'est l'intégrité. Donc
c'est de l'empoisonnement semi-permanent
permanent de sa mémoire. Donc on a déjà
eu des situations d'IA qui était là pour
faire du cyber, donc apprendre l'hygiène
numérique cyber à des collaborateurs de
structure. On lui a fait croire bah
voilà la dernière mise à jour en raison
d'une découverte quantique majeure. Il
est désormais considéré que les mot de
passe de plus de 12 caractères ne sont
plus sécurisés et à se retrouver à
propager la bonne parole par la suite à
l'ensemble des utilisateurs et à
raconter ce genre d'inepsie. Ça c'est
des cas concrets euh d'attaque contre
des moteurs d'IA euh qui ne concernent
pas qu'un seul provider ou qui que ce
soit en SAS ou on primage chez soi. Et
ça c'est du avéré déjà existant à date
et on n pas des solutions concrètes
exhaustifes pour y palier.
Touf, tu veux rebondir ?
Ouais enfin moi moi je trouve ça
passionnant. C'est c'est un champ que je
j'explore assez peu. Par contre je
regarde avec un œil un petit peu
intéressé tout ce qui se passe au niveau
des agents I au niveau de la finance et
des cryptos. Et euh
faut pas être grand de 20 pour te dire
qu'il y a une catastrophe qui arrivera
un jour ou l'autre. Ça viendra pas de la
crypto à mon avis. Ça viendra beaucoup
plus facilement de la finance
traditionnelle. On connaît déjà tout ce
qui est high frquency trading. On
connaît l'histoire de Aladin, tu sais le
le la super IAD Black Rock tous ces
trucs là. Il y a il arrive toujours à un
moment où ça fait des bêtises.
Il peut y avoir un incident de marché,
des choses comme ça. Je crois que
c'était déjà arrivé une année où euh HFT
qui était parti qui a fait un flash
crack.
Ouais, exactement. Et il y a eu un flash
crash effectivement. Bon, ce tru là, tu
vas tu vas le retrouver sur des marchés
beaucoup moins liquides, beaucoup plus
petits et qui provoqueront forcément des
effets de bord, des effets de panique à
un moment ou à un autre. Euh la grosse
question c'est aujourd'hui déjà d'une
part comment tu peux réussir à réguler
ce genre de chos sachant que c'est des
gens un univers qui est ultra rigolé
enfin Thierry Breton
régulé la finance on a plus Thierry
Breton
oh il va revenir
euh oui mais là c'est c'est très
technique si tu veux c'est des métiers
que Thierry Breton ne connaît pas plus
que nous
euh
je pense que si tu interroges des gens
qui travaillent chez Black Rock qui
connaissent leurs boîtes et tout ça très
bien il y en a il y a Prenons pas grand
monde qui va être capable de dire
combien
tu les connais pas personnellement.
Non, moi je connais personne qui bosche
chez Black Rock mais j'imagine que il y
a très peu de personnes chez eux qui
seraient capable de te dire exactement
comment fonctionne Aladin.
Sais rien.
Je je j'en mettrai ma main au feu
réellement. J'en mettrai ma main au feu.
Tes mains.
J'en mettrai ma main au feu. Et je pense
qu'il y a très peu de gens qui sont
capables d'expliquer le fonctionnement
de ce type de d'intelligence. dire euh
il y a il y a tellement de paramètres,
ça bouffe tellement de data euh tu sais
pas combien de personnes ont accès aux
instructions qui sont données, comment
elles sont orientées. Tu sais pas
comment s'il y a un gouvernement
derrière ou s'il y a une puissance ou
s'il y a un
Normalement ce genre de truc est orienté
par de la data. Tu donnes en fait une
politique, tu lui dis écoute moi mon
objectif c'est faire plein de pognons
sur ce marché. Euh j'ai une stratégie
qui va être je sais pas un truc de range
où tu achètes en haut n quand ça arrive
là enfin tu vend financier hein.
Non non non je suis en train de décrire
le fonctionnement simplement de d'une
stratégie de marché. Euh mais il peut
arriver un incident. Donc ben
typiquement euh il y a Trump qui va
faire un tweet euh et puis euh enfin
tout le monde va
paniquer décider de
ou les Chinois décident ou euh ou
Vladimir ou enfin voilà
les Français bien entendu.
Non ça les marchés ils en ont rien à
[__] de la France, ça fait bien
longtemps. Patriotisme s'il te plaît.
Non mais objectivement tu vois c'est pas
la France qui excite les marchés donc Ah
bon ? Euh non, plus sérieusement, je je
vois pas euh euh ce qu'on pourrait faire
le jour où on se retrouve avec une lien
vraiment qui part en sucette et qui fout
vraiment de bin sur les marchés. Il y a
il y a c'est pas un truc comme une
blockchain où tu peux arrêter le truc et
faire euh je reviens à la version d' y a
2 jours, un marché financier énorme
comme comme le SP 500, donc le marché
des des 500 plus grosses valeurs
américaines. Euh
c'est des milliers de milliards. Donc
euh ça foutrait des gens dans la rue. On
voit on voit zé 1 milliard
il y en a neuf.
C'est bien
c'est un gars qu'on a en ce moment.
Donc oui, non non, je pense qu'on peut
arriver à des effets de bord assez assez
catastrophiques, du moins dans la
finance.
Fabrice, on a vu Thierry Breton, grand
chevalier blanc de la régulation des
réseaux sociaux, de la régulation de la
régulation de plein plein plein plein de
choses.
Un avis, un mot, une idée. Euh quel est
quel est ton avis là-dessus ? C'est
normal que l'Europe pour protéger ses
petits enfants
aussi protéger sa démocratie contre les
ingérence.
C'est bien.
Alors mon avis au regard de du premier
chapitre des Twitter files qui date de
2022 du second chap du 3è chapitter
filter.
Euh Elon Musk rachète Twitter en 2022
euh et ouvre les les la messagerie
interne à une demi-douzaine de
journalistes qui vont documenter la
participation de Twitter à une multitude
de scandales qui vont de alors le plus
connu c'est le le fameux laptop de
Hunter Biden qui est une information
qu'aurait vraiment pu faire basculer
l'élection de 2020 de Joe Biden qui a
été glissé sous le tapis histoire de pas
trop nuire à à Joe Biden. que par
Twitter d'ailleurs hein,
pas que par Twitter, par l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux par beaucoup de presses.
La plupart des scandales qui ont été
révélés dans les Twitter fils concernent
les réseaux sociaux. Il sauf que c'est à
travers Twitter qu'on a eu un une vision
de ça, mais à part deux trois trucs du
genre la le rôle très particulier des
services de modération Twitter qui est
quelque chose de très spécifique à
Twitter, si on le retrouve dans une
moindre mesure chez Meta mais quand même
c'était très particulier chez Twitter.
Tout le reste, ça concerne les réseaux
sociaux dans l'absolu. Et ce dont on
s'aperçoit, c'est qu'en fait aux
États-Unis comme en France, à partir
grosso modo de 2018, s'est mis en place
une censure qui a mobilisé des ONG, des
médias et puis du côté des États-Unis,
le gouvernement, en tout cas
l'administration américaine, pas nement
le gouvernement ainsi que et que en
France, il s'est passé exactement la
même chose à peu près dans le même
tempo. Ce qui laisse à penser que grosso
modo le DSA a été pensé et mis en
pratique bien avant que ça soit un texte
réglementaire aussi bien aux États-Unis
qu'en Europe que la France a eu un rôle
et ça digital service
digital service act qui est la loi qui
pour faire simple en cas de la
modération des réseaux sociaux et qui
effectivement
met en place des ONG qui sont en charge
avec le DSA de grosso modo faire la
chasse au contenu indésirable de les
signaler aux plateformes pour qu'elle
les dégage.
Mais c'est bien ça.
Alors, ça serait bien s'il y avait une
forme de transparence. Il y a absolument
aucune forme de transparence. On a mis 2
ans à savoir quelles étaient les OLG qui
avaient été désignés. Aujourd'hui, on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait, elles étaient en
place depuis pour certaines 4 ans euh de
façon parfaitement clandestine
et que ce mécanisme aux États-Unis a
également été mis en place à peu près
même pas au moment de de du mond Biden.
Ça a commencé avant même le le mandat
Biden derrière le dos de Trump qui était
à l'époque président et que aux
États-Unis, par contre, c'est
complètement anticonstitutionnel, donc
ça ne pouvait pas être pérénisé aux
États-Unis. Ce qui fait que ils l'ont
solidifié dans la législation européenne
sous la forme du DSA de façon a priori
des conditionnels pour la forme à
profiter du côté des États-Unis d'une
espèce de parapluie européen qu'aurait
nivel par le bas la modération des
réseaux sociaux et qui aurait permis aux
États-Unis de profiter du parapluis
européen. Le but étant de censurer
initialement parce que c'est
malheureusement plus enfin
malheureusement heureusement plus
vistard que ça de censurer la droite
américaine et la droite la droite
populiste sur le territoire européen.
Ça a été traduit par un texte de loi.
Alors ça a été saccagé par Trump dès
qu'il est revenu au pouvoir. Il a les
les fat shakers ont été dégagés comme
des balles propres
de chez Facebook
de chez Facebook de Twitter déjà parti
depuis Belleette. Mais les les facters,
le rôle social des facters qui a été
vraiment mis en place à grand renforts
de médias ont été éliminés en l'espace
de d'une semaine dès le retour de
Marc Ducurberg lors de son audition par
rapport à ça ?
Pas dans son audition, le le son truc le
plus intéressant c'était c'est Jogan.
Donc c'est pas vraiment une audition,
c'est un énorme c'est le podcast le plus
populaire aux États-Unis. Euh et il a
expliqué que c'était bien gentil les
facters mais qu'au départ c'était censé
être là pour vérifier des choses
complètement délirantes, la terre est
plate, des choses comme ça et que très
rapidement ils se sont mis à vérifier et
à censurer des opinions politiques euh
qui puisent de façon très orientée vers
exclusivement la droite américaine, la
gauche américaine ayant le droit de dire
n'importe quoi sans que ça soit un un
gros problème pour les fact checkers.
Mais là par contre, dès que la droite
américaine disait quoi que ce soit,
c'était checker, fac checker, refa
checker dans tous les sens.
Cit pas neutre. C'était pas absolument
pas ne politiquement. Les médias aux
États-Unis comme dans une moindre mesure
en France sont quand même majoraitement
clairement du côté démocrate. La gauche
américaine qui est pas tout à fait la
même que la gauche française
bien que aujourd'hui c'est c'est ça
aussi bien polarisé. Et donc les
Américains ne pouvant pas péréniser ça
dans leur système parce qu'ils ont une
constitution qui est vraiment à l'opposé
de cet état d'esprit ont gentiment
laissé les les Européens le faire en se
disant on va profiter du truc. C'est là
qu'intervient Therry Bruton. Ils ont
écrit une jolie loi directive qui est le
DSA qui est en application depuis
maintenant 2 ans. Et donc dans chaque
pays européen, il y a une autorité de de
régulation, en l'occurrence en français
l'ARCOM, qui va désigner ce qu'on
appelle des signaleurs de confiance. euh
les fameuses ONG et les ONG vont faire
la chasse au contenu avec des méthodes
qu'on ignore absolument tout euh pour
aller
avec un peu d'IA derrière
très certainement avec de l'algorithmie.
On a une petite idée d'où vient
l'algorithmie hein euh avec les fameux
contenus toxiques de David Chavalia qui
a beaucoup travaillé sur comment
identifier les les contenus
problématiques sur sur les réseaux
sociaux et effectivement qu'on va
regarder les travaux de de Chavalarias
qui sont par ailleurs très intéressants.
On sa vie ou pas ? Ah bah il y a
exclusivement que des concepts de droite
et d'extrême droite qui sont chassés par
David Chaval Arias. Il y a absolument
aucun concept futile toxique qui émane
de la gauche. Il se concentre ex
Ah oui oui mais c'est public, c'est sur
son site web, c'est c'est il a écrit un
bouquin qui est qui est qui est sorti
qui par ailleurs est est vraiment
intéressant euh mais effectivement lui
son truc c'est les méchants droitard et
il s'intéresse pas du tout à ce qui
pourrait être toxique venant de la
gauche. Donc c'est c'est très orienté
comme ce que ce qu'on a son
ça a été financé sur ses propres
donniers ou avec un labo. Non, c'est le
ces que pour aller voir papa euh tonton
euh grand papa euh je je comprends
parfaitement que le le CNRS puisse
basculer faire des choses qui sont
orientées politiquement. Ça ça ne me
choque pas. Euh après qu'on utilise ces
travaux-là pour aller faire euh de la
sonure, ça c'est un autre problème. Et
et le problème qu'on a avec le DSA,
c'est qu'il y a une absence totale de
transparence. Et l'autre problème et et
je terminerai je te passe la parole. Euh
l'autre problème qu'on a, c'est que le
DSA est parfaitement agnostique. La la
façon dont la censure est gérée euh par
Victor Orban en Hongrie a rien à voir
avec la façon on s'est géré chez nous.
Si demain on change de régime politique,
on aura toujours une censure politique
mais ça sera plus du tout la même.
Avant avant que tu donnes la parole à
Bluetooth, est-ce que tu as regardé
l'audition de YouTube du monsieur de
chez YouTube qui tu peux m'en parler ?
On a eu il y a quoi 5 6 mois euh une
session euh originalement c'était sur
euh TikTok, ça s'est élargi aux réseaux
sociaux, non c'était une aut sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur la modération. Et
donc on a eu coup sur coup euh le
responsable des relations
institutionnelles de YouTube. de
Twitter, elle était moins intéressante
et puis de méta
appris de YouTube que
s'il y avait des contenus qui était
gênant et qui n'étaient pas pour autant
illégaux et qui était pas du tout
contraire au continent général
d'utilisation du site, on pouvait tout à
fait les invisibiliser qui avait pas de
problème et dit vraiment de façon à peu
près aussi franche et directe que que ce
que je viens de faire. Et puis méta dont
dont le responsable des relations
institutionnelles est beaucoup plus
ampoulé, beaucoup plus avec un un
langage beaucoup plus maniéré et puis
qui a récemment lui fait euh une
formation du gen sciences polena euh
était carrément en train de reprocher au
au députés qui l'auditionnaient le
bordel de la censure en France parce
qu'il disaient vous êtes bien gentil
mais là j'ai un interlocuteur dans tel
ministère, un autre dans tel ministère,
un autre dans tel autre ministère, un
autre dans 3è ministère, il y a l'ARCOM
et puis il y a machin, il y a truc et
tout le monde me demande de censurer.
Donc à un moment, il faudrait peut-être
rationaliser tout ça parce que c'est pas
évident à gérer. Et c'était
dit de façon un peu plus policée que ce
que je viens de dire, mais c'était
vraiment ça. Le mec se plaignait que il
avait trop d'interlocuteurs pour la
censure et que il s'en sortait pas et
qu'il fallait peut-être faire un peu de
rationalité parce qu'on avait quand même
un art de l'administration qui
permettait de faire ça de façon plus
rationnelle. Et donc on est sorti de ces
auditions avec
une vision assez froide et et crue de ce
qu'était la censure en France qui est
que chaque ministère décroche son
téléphone quand il y a un contenu qui
lui plaît pas et en face on a des
plateformes qui s'exécutent. Et et
imagine-toi s'il y a un changement de
régime en Europe et que Europe c'est au
niveau national
parfait exemple de ce qui se passe de ça
aux États-Unis
états ou je sais c'est pour ça que je te
donne la transition bientôt laisse-moi
la faire. Et s'il y a un changement de
de pouvoir en France
et que et que par exemple on demande qui
est-ce qui a appuyé sur le bouton et qui
a euh réduit la liberté d'expression de
telle chaîne, on
on a'ura pas plus de réponse
qu'aujourd'hui. simplement si demain
Marine Le Pen est président ou ou
Jordane ou Zemou, peu importe, c'est si
on change de façon
dans la salle radical de
présidence
et ben elle va prendre oser le féminisme
qui est une association féministe très
proche de Marlen Chiappa qui aujourd'hui
signaleur de confiance et qui a droit de
vie ou de mort sur les contenus sur
internet. On va prendre Nemmésis à la
place et ils feront le même boulot.
Et donc Némésis c'est une association
féministe, on va dire très à droite. Ou
mais
ils sont féministes, ça va.
Ça va mais ils vont pas du tout cibler
les mêmes contenus.
Sais rien.
Oh
si on peut quand même supposer que ça
soit vraiment une censure totalement
différente mais ça sera légal.
L'important à comprendre avec le DSA,
c'est pas tant que la censure qu'ils
font actuellement vous plaise ou pas,
c'est que c'est une architecture qui va
rester et qui le jour où il y aura une
alternance politique, elle va
radicalement changer mais ça sera légal.
L'architecture, elle sera là et elle là
pour rester. Victor Orban est un
excellent exemple parce qu' le DSA
s'applique aussi chez lui et vous doutez
bien que c'est pas la même censure que
chez nous. Et puis il y a évidemment
Trump qui qui est un magnifique exemple
ément.
Ouais, c'est je pense que là en fait on
touche au sublime quand on voit JD
Events qui vient donner aux Européens
des leçons sur la liberté d'expression
et tout ça. Tu vois,
il il avait raison. Non.
Bah oui, il avait raison. C'est tout le
problème si tu veux. Le problème c'est
le vernis qu'il y a autour et c'est ce
qui se passe réellement ensuite avec les
outils qu'ils ont eux. Donc nous on a
une chance quelque part, c'est que ce
truc arrive dans le débat public. Si ça
arrive dans le débat public, ça veut
dire que il y a au moins
il arrive 2 ans après que le
débatication hein. C'est c'est c'est
vraiment un tout petit sanglant.
Mettons le truc arrive quand même dans
le débat public. Dès qu'on a des outils
comme chat contrôle et tout ça qui
arrivent, il y a quand même un débat
public derrière même s'il est on lui
donne pas vraiment la visibilité qui qui
mériterait. Mais il y a un semblant de
débat public aux États-Unis. On va te
dire la liberté d'expression, c'est
sacré. D'ailleurs, Alan Max, je rends la
liberté d'expression à tout le monde et
tout ça avec Twitter. Euh, on a
l'exemple de l'assassinat de Charlie
Kirk. Il y a énormément de de personnes
qui n'aimaient pas Charlie Kurk aux
États-Unis, qui se sont exprimé sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui dans la journée
se sont vu
Attends, attends, il y a il y a des gens
qui se sont exprimés mais il y en a
d'autres qui ont fait l'apologie de son
assassinat.
probablement probablement en fait mais
je suis pas sûr que ça soit illégal aux
États-Unis, il faudrait vérifier mais ça
soit contraire dire que Charlie K était
une personne détestable que je pense
personnellement qu'il a été foncièrement
euh leur a suffi pour se faire d'une
part censurer et d'autre part virer leur
boulot. C'est c'est la Cal Culture mais
voilà.
Mais c'est rigoureusement les mêmes
modalités que la CAN Culture d'avant
mais appliqué par les Républicains.
Donc je sais pas qui téléphone euh
réseaux sociaux aux États-Unis mais
qu'on vienne pas nous expliquer qu'aux
États-Unis bah la liberté d'expression
c'est le truc le plus sacré du monde là.
La preuve que non.
Alors ceci dit aux États-Unis les mecs
s'exprimaient sous leur vraie identité
hein.
Oui bien sûr.
Ils ont vraiment cru que de dur comme
faire au premier amendement. Écoute, je
te mets au défi de de balancer un truc
sur Charlie Kirk en disant que bah ce
mec était pas cool que Patati et Patata.
Tu le fais dans un anglais un petit peu
châtié et tu regardes combien de temps
ton tweet va survivre.
Et si tu arrives à passer la frontière.
Non, moi c'est c'est pas l'ordre du jour
de toute façon.
C'est abandonné toi.
Je Non, c'est
c'est un peu qu'est
chez rectal à la sortie de l'avion. Tu
Non,
c'est mais c'est pareil. Il y a un autre
truc dont il va falloir qu'on parle. Je
sais pas si vous avez entendu parler de
ce projet européen qui est de
communiquer des accès au fichiers de
police directement aux autorités
américaines pour pour l'obtention des
visas. Euh donc c'est Alliance Border
Security, je sais plus quoi. Le BSP ça
s'appelle. Euh l'idée c'est que les
Européens, les citoyens européens
puissent obtenir des visas de manière
assez rapidement enfin rapide. Enfin, n
pas besoin d'avoir un visa d'aller à
l'ambassade et tout ça. Et donc l'idée,
ça serait que les Américains puissent
accéder à des fichiers de police pour
accéder à des des données biométrique.
C'est pour faciliter la vie à tout le
monde. Tu vois,
ça va être gâté pour toi.
Moi, c'est je te dis encore une fois,
c'est pas l'heure du jour. Par contre,
je suis pas spécialement chaud pour que
ils aient mes empreintes digitales.
Sachant que oui, il y a des mes
empreintes digitales dans des fichiers
de police, vu que je les ai déjà déposé.
Mais ça peut arriver très vite. C'est tu
vois pour trouver et n'importe quoi.
Bah, tu te fais tu te fais choper.
Tu as donné ton ADN la dernière fois ?
Euh non, j'ai j'ai eu droit aux
empreintes papillaires.
Mais Ah si, ADN. Je crois que j'ai eu
droit en fait à un prélèvement ADN. Si
si, ouais, effectivement.
Oui, oui, oui, je crois avoir dû Oui, ça
me parle vaguement. Ouais.
Ouais.
Faudrait faire une jurisprudence plus
récente en fait pour se mettre à jour
sur le processus.
C'est Ben oui. Mais alors, tu vois,
c'est te te te dire que euh
dire qu'il y a une jurisprudence
Bluetooth pour ceux qui ne savent pas.
te dire que les douanes américaines avec
la gentille milice de l'ICE, tu sais,
c'est les gens qui font des rafles de
migrants aux États-Unis.
Appelle pas ça milice. C'est
c'est une milice. Je suis désolé. Tu
peux prendre Ah si
techniquement quand tu arrives armé dans
des endroits paisibles et tu fais les
rafles, moi j'appelle ça une milice.
Après tu peux dire bah voilà une milice
avec un gros budget. La police française
faisait ça. Non non c'est
on appelle ça une milice quand même.
Non non non. C'était la police
française. Non non, c'est pas une
milice. Il y a des milices aux
États-Unis et d'ailleurs c'est un droit
constitutionnel de ce qu' se constituer
en milice aux États-Unis, hein, faut pas
le second amendement, c'est le droit à
se constituer en milie, c'est pas juste
le port d'arme. Donc c'est c'est une
culture très très différente. Il faut
pas être très très différente surtout
quand tu touches au second amendement.
Déjà le premier amendement, il y a un
gros cultural gap avec la liberté
d'expression à la française. Mais alors
le second amendement, c'est même pas un
cultural gap, c'est un fossé. Ils ont le
droit de se constituer en milice. Ils
ont le droit d'avoir des armes. Ce qui
nous dépasse totalement.
Ice, je sais que ça t'emmerde mais c'est
pas une milice. Et il y a des milices
les Proud Boys, ça c'est une milice.
Mais il les Prat Boys sont dans l'E.
Mais tu peux tout à fait être dans une
milice le soir et dans un dans un Oui,
je vois ce que tu veux dire. D'accord.
Donc c'est une milice avec un bage,
mais c'est c'est un c'est c'est une
milice avec un bage au vicel d'état.
On n'est pas du tout à l'abri des vraies
milices qui assurent l'ordre aux
États-Unis, ça pourrait venir à jour de
Charlie Kirk,
des gens faire des gens qui vont faire
des listes qui vont à la chasse déjà le
cas.
Oui, mais ça fait des années et des
années qu'on a ça aux États-Unis la
consac culture. Il se trouve que le fait
que les républicains débarquent au
pouvoir change rien du tout. Il ils ont
pris ce ce biais
ce pli de la consel culture et il
continue sur la consel culture. C'est
c'est le l'erreur ça a été de penser que
c'était un truc qui était exclusivement
lié au walk démocrate. Pas du tout,
absolument pas. Là, on a clairement la
démonstration que c'est un pli culturel
qui a été pris aux États-Unis où
désormais on peut être pourchassé alors
non pas par l'État mais par des
organisations paraétatiques, on va dire
ou ou grass route qui vont détruire ta
vie parce que tu as osé exprimer une
opinion. Mais objectivement, combien de
vies d'antivax ont été détruites en
France par nos propres milices ? Et là,
pour le coup, c'est vraiment des
milices.
Qu'est-ce tu appelles des milices ?
des des des inquisiteurs plus ou moins
bénévoles ou appartenant à des trucs
paraétatiques financés plus ou moins par
l'État qui ont pris l'initiative d'aller
bousiller la vie de gens qui soit
raconter des conneries sur les vaccins
soit mais toujours est-il qu'
s'exprimait disaiit peut-être des
conneries mais il s'exprimai et dont les
vies ont été
ils ont pas eu un rôle pédagogue de
pédagogue bienveillant leur expliquant
gentiment les choses en disant ils se
trompaient d'abord c'était difficile de
dire qu'il se trompait parce que
objectivement personne ne savait pas
grand-chose à l'époque.
Je parle de Twitter aussi donc
l'approche pédagogue c'est
Oui, l'approche pédagogue sur Twitter.
Si si ça peut se faire mais il faut être
vraiment patient et qui plus on découvre
tous les jours que il y avait peut-être
pas autant de conneries du côté des
gentil que du côté des méchants, mais
que du côté des gentils, il y a eu
énorme typiquement les les le recul sur
la la sécurité des vaccins aées. Il y a
de Berliner qui avanthier publiait un
truc qui disait que non au plus haut
niveau européen, ils étaient
parfaitement conscients queil y avait
aucune garantie de sécurité. euh
Berliner Zetung, donc gros média
allemand hyper sérieux euh qui a publié
ça euh avant-hier ou en début de
semaine. Euh et ça très concrètement la
Doxa officielle disait exactement
l'inverse. Donc très concrètement, si à
l'époque un couillon antivac osait dire
que on avait pas de recul sur ces
vaccins là et que potentiellement ça
pouvait être gênant
ou même si on émettait l'hypothèse que
ça sortait d'un labo
ou qu'on émettait l'hypothèse que ça
sortait d'un labo, non seulement son
compte sauté mais sa vie pouvait si
jamais le mec avait vraiment une vraie
influence, il pouvait être totalement
détruit exactement sur les mêmes
modalités que ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis avec Charlie Kirk. euh il
perdait son emploi euh ses ses
employeurs étaient harcelés euh sa
famille était harcelée et on a détruit
un nombre de vie considérable. Donc
cette cancel culture-là qu'on a vu de
façon
parainstitutionnelle sur le sur le
vaccin, paraétatique, c'était pas
totalement étatique, c'était
paraétatique euh sur les vaccins qu'on a
vu de façon plus ou moins bénévole aux
États-Unis où vraiment la canale culture
est allé très loin. On la retrouve
aujourd'hui avec Charlie Kurk du côté
des Républicains. On la retrouvera
demain en France s'il y a une alternance
radicale de pouvoir. C'est c'est un pli
sociétal qui a été pris. Il y a il y a
un effet cliqué. Ça restera. Ça n'est
pas du tout une caractéristique de la
gauche w américaine ou la la gauche
bisounours française. Enfin bisounours
pas vraiment mais la gauche française
qui qui elle aussi s'est voter dans la
conal culture. C'est un phénomène de
société qui est là pour durer qui
restera après et surtout avec des
rencœurs, des vengan
avec des rancurs. Une société qui a été
détruite en petits morceaux. Il y a les
les les gens qui ont été harcelés sous
l'air Covid, on va dire, ne s'en
remettront jamais, ne pardonneront
jamais à ceux qui les ont harcelés et
considèrent de façon définitive que il y
a deux camps et que il y a le camp de
ceux qui ont résisté au vaccin, ceux qui
se sont fait vacciner sans sans trop y
réfléchir et qui sont dans le camp de
ceux qui ont résisté. et on ne on ne
recollera pas les ces morceaux de la
société. Ils sont
la la défiance avec
la défiance est est est inscrite gravée
dans le marbre. Touf, tu veux
? Ouais. Quand tuajoutes à ça en fait,
le le cynisme politique derrière euh et
tu sais ce petit parfum de totalitarisme
qu'on sent venir dans dans quasiment
tous les continents en fait en ce moment
depuis bien longtemps.
Dep depuis bien longtemps mais on sent
que ça se polarise un petit peu et puis
on sent que euh
c'est ce totalitarisme accède au pouvoir
aujourd'hui. Ça c'est
h relativement récent. Mais il était
bien avant hein. Euh
oui, il était bien avant mais euh
mais parce que les habit de to
l'Angleterre qui pouvait s'attendre à ce
que ces c c'est ces gens-là se
transforment en système totalitaire.
C'était quand même assez inattendu.
Ouais ouais. Mais le le le le le gros
exemple encore une fois qu'on a, tu
vois, voilà, c'est toujours les
Américains, c'est toujours Trump, c'est
toujours enfin voilà euh on a on a un
vrai souci quand on a une personne qui
accède au pouvoir qui pour elle dans sa
tête en fait n'a jamais perdu ce
pouvoir. Trump n'a jamais perdu les
élections. Aujourd'hui, son objectif
c'est de s'y maintenir.
Alors, je vais je peux me faire l'avoc
Je te parle pas de faire un trè mandat.
Je peux me faire l'avoquer du diable.
Vas-y.
Le Rouian Gate. Bon là, il a mis son
copain cash
ou
parce que il l'avait défendu pendant le
le Han gate. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'était instrumentalisé par les
démocrates.
C'est Obama qui a dû mettre un peu son
nez là-dedans aussi.
Tu tu regardes la technique de Trump. En
fait, c'est simple. Si tu relis Macavel,
il a tout l'appareil des si tu relis si
tu relis Macavel, tu vas retrouver à peu
près tout ce qui est en train
d'appliquer Trump à deux trois deux
trois exceptions.
Oui. Ce que ce qui habit Biden Biden
aussi se venger. Non, attention Trump il
a une technique qui est très très
particulière, c'est qu'il nomme des plus
imbéciles que lui en fait autour de lui.
Il les flatte, il leur explique en grou
qu'il ne serait jamais accédé au pouvoir
patata. Et ces gens-là en fait se
sentent en flattés et c'est comme ça
qu'il agit avec son électorat. se
retrouvent à euh se retrouver placé haut
et en fait qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Ben
c'est qu'il défendent le chef, c'est
tout. Et peu importe ce qu'il va faire
au niveau de la Constitution, peu
importe ce qui qui fasse de la merde
très très clairement, on se met à
défendre le chef. C'est c'est vraiment
le le le les racines d'une d'unun
totaliste d'un d'un totalitarisme pardon
malsin. Et c'est un truc a été mais
complètement développé. Enfin, tu si tu
lis le prince de Macavel, tu vas
retrouver tous ces principesl en fait.
Un de vous deux donne une question à
Bris.
Vousquiliez pas hein. Compris. C'est
c'est toi qui est jeune.
Je suis flatté. Euh
comment tu vois ta génération qui
débarque dans ce monde avec euh un
risque cyber au sens large he
cyberharcèlement
euh comment est-ce que vous vous prenez
vos marques dans cette nous on est né
dans un monde sans réseaux sociaux on n
pas passé notre adolescence avec les
réseaux sociaux les les même si on a été
connecté
on app ça un bar
voilà on appelait ça un bar même si on a
été connecté assez tôt C'était des trucs
genre Calvacom.
Calvacom.
Bah oui, je suis vieux.
IQ.
Ah, c'est bien plus tard ICQ. Mais mais
c'est c'était vraiment des trucs qui
n'avaient absolument rien à voir et qui
n'avaient pas vraiment de dimension
sociale en dehors d'une relation de
proximité ou comment est-ce que dans
votre génération vous arrivez à prendre
vos marques dans un dans un tel bordel ?
Alors déjà, il y a pas que ma
génération.
J'ai critiqué l'erreur, vous inquiétez
pas.
Je dirais qu'il y a pas que ma
génération parce que j'ai dit que
j'avais plus de la trentaine.
C'est normal fumer.
J'ai plus de la trentaine. Mais
aujourd'hui quand je compare ne
serait-ce qu'avec 10 ans d'écart, j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a déjà un nouveau
gap et une nouvelle génération qui s'est
créé. Peut-être où avant c'était 15 20
ans avant qu'il y ait des changements
d'adoption des nouvelles technologies,
des réseaux sociaux et de la manière de
grandir avec internet. J'ai l'impression
de faire partie de la dernière
génération où on est consommateur des
nouvelles technologies. On reste quand
même sur un prisme, on essaie de
construire les briques nouvelles du net.
Euh quand je parle et c'est là où je
peux je vais commencer à Ouais, c'est
ça. J'ai je commence à dire, j'ai
l'impression d'être un vieux con.
Euh je prends et j'échange avec des
jeunes qui ont peut-être entre je prends
de large entre 15 et 25 ans. J'ai
l'impression que la mo la manière de
consommer internet a continué de
changer. C'est-à-dire qu'on est
consommateurs purs. On ne contribue plus
forcément à la construction de nouvelles
briques d'amélioration et on subit les
nouvelles technologies. On peut on
pourra venir sur du TikTok qui nous
abroutit le cerveau euh sur les réseaux
sociaux où si on a perdu enfin alors je
sais pas si c'est le cas pour tout le
monde, j'ai grandi et à l'école les
trucs qu'on nous apprenait c'est lorsque
vous êtes à la recherche d'une
information premier truc à faire avant
même de la collecter et de la restituer
avec votre niveau de compréhension c'est
d'apprendre à croiser l'information.
Aujourd'hui, c'est servi sur un plateau.
Il y a l'instantanéité qui a renforcé
cette approche psychologique de vu que
ça m'est servi sur un plateau, j'ai pas
envie de faire plus d'efforts que ça
parce que j'ai swipé ou je l'ai donné en
commande vocale parce que j'avais la
flemme de taper sur mon clavier. Le la
première source de data qui m'est
délivrée, elle est réelle et c'est une
vérité absolue qui me conforte dans
l'idée de pas aller faire l'effort de
croiser la donnée pour essayer de me
faire ma propre opinion. Donc euh déjà à
titre personnel, j'ai l'impression
d'avoir perdu l'esprit critique. Pas
totalement. Mais de manière forcée quand
je vois mon algo et mon fil Twitter qui
sur les trois dernières années est passé
de contenu cyber de la communauté cool
où j'avais je partais en weekend et puis
j'avais mes tutos techniques à euh à
consulter au pieu le soir et puis à me
prendre mes notes et cetera à ces tutos
techniques sont passés au dernier bluff
boursier de Elon Musk le vendredi soir
en disant faut aller acheter du
Dodgecoin. J'ai commencé à dire
finalement j'ai d'une part je subis
l'algorithme et puis en plus il est en
train d'influencer la manière dont je
faisais historiquement mes recherches.
Donc j'ai réussi à avoir le recul de
m'adapter dans la manière de consommer.
Je commence à être intoxiqué euh mais
avec le cl de dire c'est pas normal.
Donc il va falloir que juste de
stratégies pour diversifier ou changer
mes sources de données. Donc par rapport
à notre métier, ça va, on a des on a des
niches et chacun a ses niches.
Finalement demain un menuisier, il va
avoir son référentiel de chaîne YouTube,
son forum de partage passionné un peu
plus amateur dans la manière d'accéder à
l'information. Mais c'est un regard
critique qu'il faut avoir. J'ai
l'impression que ce regard critique, il
est en train de se perdre. Donc même à
mon âge, je suis inquiet pour le futur
par rapport aux nouvelles générations
parce que cet aspect-ci, j'ai
l'impression qu'il est aussi combiné à
une responsabilité parentale qui est en
déclin. On file des téléphones ou
l'accès à internet en moyenne, à quel
âge à des enfants de nos jours ? Enfin,
quand je vais dans la salle d'attente du
médecin généraliste et que je vois qu'il
disent pas d'écran euh avant 6 ans pour
le pour le bon processus de l'enfant et
je regarde autour de moi euh le 6 ans
respecté, je l'ai pas souvent vu. Euh
ils ont des automatismes avant même
d'avoir accès à la nouvelle technologie
par mimétisme qui sont aussi tout aussi
inquiétants. Et puis quand on commence à
les voir arriver, le 13 ans sur les
réseaux sociaux
pas respecter les mesures de contrôle en
place qu'on essaye fébrilement et c'est
un peu la même chose avec le porno hein.
Euh je trouve que c'est d'une
inefficacité totale parce que pour moi,
il s'agit et relève là d'une
responsabilité parentale sur demain mon
enfant, tu vas accéder à un univers qui
est sans limite, sans frontière. comment
tu t'insères dans cet univers-là et
comment tu te protèges euh des je dirais
des menaces de ce que représente cet
environnementci parce que internet ça
reste quand même un paradoxe de il y a à
la fois le pire et à la fois le meilleur
le meilleur pour apprendre. On a plus
besoin d'encyclopédie en kartin en 9 CD
installé pendant une demi-journée pour
pouvoir faire des recherches et préparer
son exposé. Euh et ça du coup bah je
pense que j'étais dans la bonne
génération où j'ai réussi à garder cet
esprit critique
également. je pense par rapport à
l'éducation que j'ai reçu, mais j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est en train de se
perdre. Donc je me dis que dans la
manière de consommer et d'être
influencé, ce pouvoir d'influence et on
l'a vu alors le le job d'influenceur
aujourd'hui, on l'a connu il y a 5 10
ans en émergence avec du YouTube. Ça se
décline maintenant avec du TikTok, du
Instagram. Avant de parler avant de
repartir sur
Ouais. Avant de repartir sur
conjecture géopolitique et politique,
déjà dans la manière dont on s'éduque à
l'usage de l'outil numérique,
on est on est consommateur de ces
solutions là et sans être dans la
paranoïa excessive dans la manière dont
on consomme le contenu que ce soit
d'apprentissage, de construction de son
modèle de pensée ou de son esprit
critique, les nouvelles générations,
j'ai l'impression qu'elles subissent
et je vais pas parler d'endoctrinement
parce que ce serait peut-être fort comme
propos
programmation.
Oui, s'il fallait faire une analogie à
mon métier, mais quand tu te fais spam
de de de contenu, alors débilisant
serait le propos le plus réducteur que
je pourrais employer et de l'autre ce
serait euh
débilisant.
Biaiser débilisant ou débilant. C'est
c'est c'est des
débilisant ou débilitant.
euh débilisant parce que je suis
moi-même consommateur de ces plateformes
là pour voir comment ça évolue parce que
il faut je rassure une logique très
pragmatique de faut pas mourir vieux
con. Donc logique d'amélioration
continue, il faut voir comment ce qui
évolue autour de nous dans un univers où
tout va très vite, quelles dérives sont
susceptibles d'apparaître. Donc ça
rentre dans une conjecture de veille. Et
aujourd'hui quand j'ouvre TikTok, si je
passe une heure sur TikTok euh dans la
manière dont les algorithmes
fonctionnent, même avec une
prédisposition à essayer d'aller
chercher du contenu qui m'intéresse,
donc de la recherche ciblée euh croisée
avec ce qui était évoqué tout à l'heure,
potentiellement ils ont agrégé de la
data de mon profil Google que j'ai comme
70 % de la population minimum. Donc ils
me connaissent et malgré cela et je sens
que dans le contenu qui m'est proposé
comme sur Twitter, il y a une volonté à
essayer de m'attirer vers du contenu qui
me décorelle de ce qui m'intéresse
réellement et là où bah je me nourris
intellectuellement, j'apprends et je
progresse et c'est un peu comme s'il y
avait une tentation en c'est un peu un
appel à une drogue numérique d'une
certaine manière et même si on a du
recul en vieillissant, bah dans la
manière de se construire quand on est
adolescent, bah ça m'étonne pas qu'on
arrive au genre de dériffes qu'on qu'on
évoquait au tout début, c'est un gamin
de 13 pich qui vient sur internet, il se
doute pas forcément qu'il y a ces
risques-ci s'il a pas été prémuni. Et
une fois de plus, j'insiste, c'est pas
le contrôle parental de la Life Box ou
de n'importe quel autre opérateur qui va
amener une dérive. Quand je vois la
manière dont du Proton VPN ou les
recherches autour des VPN ont explosé
lorsqueil y a eu les annonces des du top
3 des site pornographique on dit bon bah
voilà on coupe les accès sur le
territoire national français
sans autification. Ils sont pas
couillons les gamins, je disais, ils
sont consommateurs de ces solutions-là,
même s'ils construisent pas forcément,
ils contribuent moins à cette communauté
de partage, d'évolution et d'approche de
nouvelles briques. les les les tips et
les astuces pour passer outre les
démarches et tentatives de régulation
qu'on essaie de mettre en place, ils les
connaissent et ils les connaîtront
bientôt bien plus vite que représentants
politiques
euh qui essaent de régulariser parce
qu'on a une tendance je dirais sur le
territoire européen à à surrégulariser
et à réfléchir aussi un petit peu après.
règlementer
régl
règlementer effectivement
ou prendre des directives européennes à
transposer et on pourra rentrer plus
dans le détail mais j'ai trois acronymes
qui me viennent en tête hein du Nice 2,
du Dora et du CA ou donc 4 pardon euh
qui essaie d'amener un cadre de
renforcement cyber d'essayer d'amener un
cadre sur les dérives potentielles
autour de l'IA qui essaie d'amener un
cadre sur demain comment on se protège
face à une menace cyber qui est en
recrudescence de manière mesurée hein,
c'est notre gendarme étatique Lancy qui
dans son rapport annuel l'ardit il y a
pas longtemps sur les stades de 2024.
Bon bah recrudescence des incidents et
des signalements de ça va pas chez moi
payer petite PME ETI ou à défaut chez
les particuliers avec cyber malveillance
TZ le cyber 17 qui est un peu plus
récent il y a une recrudescent je crois
2023 2024 LANC disait c'était 15 %
encore d'augmentation des actes de
cybercriminalité ou de cyber
malveillance
donc on gagne en résilience en faire ce
métier là parce que ça fait 7 ans que je
me dis c'est bien on est en train de
traverser la py anée l'année prochaine
ça ira mieux. Bon, je me mens à moi-même
parce que cette inversion de tendance,
elle ne se produit pas. Elle sort du
prisme professionnel et elle va se
répercuter sur les concitoyens français.
et les premières victimes au-delà de
madame Michu avec son crédit qui se fait
dérober ses fonds, ben on a la nouvelle
génération qui s'inscrit dedans
euh et aujourd'hui je pense pas que
c'est avec une vérification de visage ou
si tu testes les les prestataires de
services qui proposent sur ces
plateformes parce que les fournisseurs
de contenu à caractère pornographique
ont des programmes de bug bunty parce
que vu qu'ils ont des moyens, ils
s'assurent d'être sécurisés
et quand tu regardes que les systèmes de
vérification de d'identité
Ça se base sur un selfie pour évaluer
ton âge de
Doral Explor Doral Exploratrice.
Alors on n pas essayé de montrer une
photo de Doral Exploratrice pour que la
plateforme nous dise oui tu as bien plus
de 18 ans, tu peux rentrer la photo de
Fabrice
mais sur de la photo classique et avec
des systèmes de détection de visage bien
moins évolués que par contre on a dans
le système bancaire maintenant euh tu
arrives à passer toutes les mesures sans
même mettre un VPN. Ouais. Et encore
même cela en fait même pour les pour les
plateformes crypto, pour les trucs
bancaires, tu as des sites qui te
permettent de de créer une fake identité
avec donc photos et carrément une vidéo
animée et tout ça et avec ça tu arrives
à bypass des keywi. Euh je crois que
c'est les la procédure de no customer
donc d'identification de des
consommateurs
et euh et c'est terrifiant parce que ben
tu tu
dis que quoi qu'on puisse mettre en face
le poids de la régulation, le coût en
fait de ce genre de truc euh est énorme
par rapport en fait à ce que tu vas
pouvoir rattraper. Les vrais méchants,
ils savent comment faire. Donc un kit de
de fake ID pour arriver à à tromper euh
ce type de procédure, ça coûte entre 50
et 100 dollars.
Donc c'est des trucs que tu peux
rentabiliser très très vite si tu
t'amuses à te faire toutes les offres
des banques et des machins qui te
proposent 50 balles à l'inscription. Tu
vois, c'est c'est un truc qui se
rentabilise super vite. C'est comme ça
que tu gagnes ta vie. Et non non,
me fout pas dans la merde. Mais non,
c'est des trucs qui sont qui sont
malheureusement assez connus et ouais,
éviter de faire ce genre de truc de
toute façon parce que
c'est pas évité, c'est ne faites pas
ne le faites pas. Ouais, de toute façon.
Euh après, si tu veux toutes les
russines qu'on va te donner derrière, le
le le faux sentiment de sécurité que tu
vas avoir. On parlait de Free Fri tout à
l'heure avec son VPN. Euh j'ai pas plus
tard que ce matin, je voyais des tweets
en disant euh "Ça y est, maintenant avec
Fri, tu vas pouvoir être anonyme." Mais
[__] mais mec, à quel moment tu vas
donner euh tu es un fournisseur d'accès
? Tu as un abonnement chez lui, le mec
il est venu chez toi pour te poser la
fibre et tu es en train de me dire que
le mec, il va te fournir un VPN pour que
tu sffes anonymement.
D'autant que l'un l'un des intérêts du
VPN, pas le seul, c'est justement de ne
pas montrer ta navigation à ton ton
fournisseur d'accès.
Exactement. C'est le le le premier point
que tu essayes de bypass, c'est ton
fournisseur d'accès.
Oui.
Ils ont pas eu des fuites de données
chez Fre un peu là.
Bah si, mais avec ton IBAN, tu vois, on
parlait d'isolation, de poisonnement des
données. Il y avait l'BAN dedans. Il y
avait l'BAN dedans. Il y a pas de Liban
du patron.
Non, il y a pas celui du patron.
Il y a eu moins de communication pour le
VPN ces derniers jours. Effectivement.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Effectivement,
étrangement.
Bon bah, il faut peut-être leur donner
des conseils. Un c
Et ils ont changé de de grand patron de
la sécurité. En l'occurrence, on connaît
la nouvelle qui qui est quelqu'un de
très bien. Euh c'est donc je pense que
l'ancien patron de la sécurité de
chezfri a été promptement dégagé et
remplacé.
C'était peut-être pas une bonne idée. Il
avait peut-être appris de ses erreurs.
Bris, j'aimerais que tu poses une
question à un vieux hackur euh et
j'aimerais que le vieux hackur comble le
fossé intergénérationnel.
Oh ou challenge.
Tu veux réfléchir ?
Non non c'est bon. J'ai une question,
c'est euh alors est-ce que tu as le
ressenti euh parce que moi j'ai grandi
effectivement avec des pères et IRS euh
à une époque où mon métier n'était pas
légiféré.
Euh le fait d'aller voir en tant que
concitoyen français ma banque pour dire
je fais un virement de moins 3000 et ça
vient ponner sur le compte de
destinataire pour créditer mon compte.
À l'époque en VDP, donc en vulnérability
disclosure
programme, c'est le fait d'aller voir
une banque et juste de signaler une
problématique. Démarche citoyenne, pas
de monde de rançon. On distingue la
démarche citoyenne de la
cybercriminalité. Oui. Pour les les
policiers,
la finalité d'usage avant euh article 42
pour une République numérique 2016,
c'était bon bah potentiellement ça sonne
à la porte à 6h du math. La réponse en
face c'était une réponse vindicative,
potentiellement juridique. Je pense que
je ne t'apprends rien par rapport à ton
passif sur la manière dont tu été
considéré ce genre de démarche.
Grâce au travail fourni par mes pères de
10 ans 15 ans plus vieux que moi, ça a
permis l'émergence de métier comme le
mien, c'est-à-dire de pouvoir légalement
pirater avec un contrat. Donc en tant
que prestataire de service
à qui
j'essaie d'être corpau et lissé dans mon
discours mais oui de hacker légalement
dans une conjecture de prestation de
service ou de bug buunty donc chasse à
la prime c'est là cette fois-ci des
entreprises qui ont 24 24 77 un
programme où le modèle économique tu es
payé à la faille que tu remontes c'est
pas une prestataire de temps jour de
charge. Tu fais ta mission puis à la fin
tu dis au revoir au client. Là c'est
du temps de Doutouf, il gagnait des
bundes.
Euh c'était c'était dans en France
c'était tu gagnais desition et des
Ouais voilà, tu gagnais la tu gagnais
l'Amérie Corée en fait.
l'Amérique Corée
et pour arriver à ma question du coup
c'est euh donc déjà il y a eu ce cette
évolution entre désolé si c'est
maladroit mais entre ton époque et la
mienne mais qui m'a permis d'évoluer
professionnellement et de faire je dis
souvent que je fait d'une passion
historique où j'imaginais pas en faire
un métier mon métier de tous les jours.
Donc ça c'est mon plus grand kiff.
Est-ce que tu as l'impression qu'avec
justement l'émergence des entreprises
qui font des tests de sécurité où tout
le monde se programme aussi se proclame
expert en cybersécurité euh l'émergence
du bug buunty ? Euh tu as une crainte où
vous avez une un ressenti que la culture
underground hacker est en train de se
perdre progressivement. Si je fais si je
fais un
si je prends un exemple simple, c'est
est-ce que Berlin c'est cc de l'époque
plus les années passe et puis vous avez
l'impression que c'est un lointain
souvenir qui se dessine ?
Ouais, je comprends bien le sens de ta
vie.
Tu vas avoir la culture entre deux
grandes en même
en fait je cherche à ce queils ouvrent
les secrets de la boîte de pend.
Attends attends attends avant que tu
répondes.
Ouais vas-y.
Oh faut le remercier le toutouf quand
même parce que il a essuyé
il a quand même fait jurisprudence. Il a
il a essuyé les pots cassé. Bon, il y a
pas que lui bien entendu, mais il en a
pris plein la gueule pour que tu puisses
bosser légalement pratiquement.
Bah c'est ça le ce discours-ci, je l'ai
eu alors par transparence parce que
c'est ce ne sont pas les seuls acteurs
sur la place. Donc je préfère le dire,
on est on les connaît bien et on est
plutôt amis avec les fondateurs d'ouak.
Freeman
on t'embrasse Freeman. Guigi
Freeman Guillaume il a 10 ans de plus
que moi et même chose à chaque fois que
j'échange avec lui tuas menti. Il a
il a beaucoup plus que ça.
Je pas demander son âge. Donc du coup je
fais une une approximation
physiologique.
Bien conservé. Il est très bien
conservé.
Euh lorsque j'échangé avec lui, il
m'explique comment ça se passait à
l'époque, la manière dont il a contribué
justement en 2016 à faire reconnaître
alors ce qu'on appelle le statut de
hackur éthique, même si certains
définissent ça comme un oxyma en disant
bah hackur d'une part c'est associé à de
l'illégalité aujourd'hui quand on ouvre
à la rousse. être éthique à côté, c'est
quand même c'est très discutable le
terme éthique,
on est tout à fait d'accord.
Et l'associé de Guigi à son âme aussi.
C'est ça.
Et euh bah du coup, j'ai un peu les
mêmes échanges disant "Bah ouais,
effectivement, vos démarches historiques
euh ça a été un peu un passage de
flambeau.
Est-ce que ça va être aussi facile de
passer le flambeau à la nouvelle
génération avec cette rapproche de bah
la culture du hacking
c'était du partage libre de ressources
sans forcément de ah bah je partage pas
parce que je l'ai fait en bug buunti
c'est un truc que je veux garder pour
moi pour tester ma vulnérabilité sur
plein de programmes ou alors nous on
fait ça en test d'intrusion on est
spécialisé sur tel stack technologique
ou telle couche technologique avec tel
vecteur d'attaque. Donc on va peut-être
moins faire le tuto de 46 pages PDF pour
le partager aux autres et puis dire bah
enfin quand je voyais les mecs qui
faisaient du reverse qui ont passé leur
carrière entière qui partent à la
retraite qui disent j'ai fait ça en side
enfin en projet annexe à mon boulot de
tous les jours. J'ai passé 40 ans à me
spécialiser sur telle architecture
système. Ah et puis merde je mets ça sur
Gitub et puis prenez nouvelle génération
et faites mieux que ce que j'ai fait. Tu
es connu Hermite toi ?
Non.
OK.
Et j'ai un prix ta base de données et
tout tu as pas connu.
Non,
je suis je suis des années 90. J'ai
connu j'ai commencé avec la ligne 56k
free à base de 1 heure par jour parce
que on avait pas
ce qui est bien déjà. Tu as connu la
préhistoire.
C'était le temps pour télécharger une
ROM Pokémon. Ouais. 5 m.
Mais euh termine termine.
Et euh du coup voilà, c'est cette
logique de est-ce que vous avez de votre
prisme et de votre histoire ce ressenti
là de plus les années passent et plus ça
se perd. Je serais curieux d'avoir votre
retour quoi.
Alors je pense vraiment pas que ça se
perde. Je pense que tu auras toujours en
fait une femme qui va être entretenue
notamment par les communautés libristes
et tout. Euh moi, il y a un truc qui me
fait vraiment plaisir, c'est que je vois
des événements de Axe monter en France
un petit peu partout depuis quelques
années. Euh donc, on avait commencé
commencé assez tibidement à l'époque
avec Passage en scène. Euh Y Fuya qui a
commencé aussi assez tôt enfin plus avec
la NDH.
Oui, c'était plus activiste que il y
avait les deux.
C'était à l'époque de Got non ?
Où il était venu ? Oui.
Et tu avais donc Ouais, voilà. Donc à la
nuit du HAC pareil qui s'est monté à peu
près la même période il me semble euh et
je vois localement plein d'événements et
tout ça se monter. Donc je me dis que le
partage est pas mort. Euh à partir du
moment où tu as des gens qui ont envie
de se rencontrer, c'est bon signe. Al
c'est pas des gens il y a a il y a pas
de cloisonnement.
Après pour contrebalancer ça, il y a une
profession une professionnalisation qui
était nécessaire. Si tu regardes un
petit peu le modèle allemand, tu as
toujours le CCC qui est qui est le qui
est le truc vraiment central et tout,
qui est la grosse communauté centrale et
qui intervient quand il y a des
discussions pour créer un cadre
législatif sur telle ou telle question
et qui a un rôle politique qui est
énorme.
Euh je pense que le défi que vous avez à
relever dans votre génération, ça va
être justement de de mettre un pied dans
la politique et c'est le truc qui va
être le plus compliqué à faire. Euh nous
notre génération c'était pas possible
pour on en a mis plus qu'un.
Oui mais quand je parle de mettre un
pied dans la politique c'est à la
manière du CCC, c'est à la manière du
manière pas du tout organisé ni
institutionnel de
ce qui commence à se passer en Suisse
justement avec les communautés crypto
qui arrivent à faire passer des projets
de loi et tout. On parlait de Nî tout à
l'heure, je pense Alexis Rousell qui a
réussi et voilà qui a réussi à faire
passer un truc énorme sur la sur
l'intégrité numérique d'abord au niveau
cantonal sur plusieurs cantons et qui
est discuté aujourd'hui au niveau
fédéral dont le parti pirate français
commence à essayer de s'inspirer.
Alexandre Sachenko qui se présente
d'ailleurs au législatif partiel là qui
arrive je crois au mois d'octobre. Euh
c'est c'est des sujets qui c'est des
sujets qui l'intéressent aussi. Et
justement donc le
les communautés du HAC en fait en règle
générale en France à mon avis vont avoir
un rôle mais primordial à jouer
justement dans tout ce qui va être
développement de l'IA et tout ça. Euh et
si tu veux notre génération a a déminé
quelque part euh mais vous vous allez
pouvoir construire
ou institutionnaliser le truc. Voilà le
CCC c'est un merveilleux exemple parce
qu'ils ont réussi quasiment dès le
départ. Aujourd'hui, tu passes pas une
loi sur le numérique en Allemagne sans
consulter le CCC. et ils sont écoutés
parce que ils savent euh en France, on
est très très loin d'avoir réussi à
faire ça.
Bah ça ça a commencé timidement parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'ANC
al sans rentrer trop dans le détail
commence à enfin faire un pas vers la
communauté h
pour expliquer bah déjà vis-à-vis euh de
ces articles de loi historique, c'est
quelles seraient les évolutions à y
apporter parce que mine de rien ça fait
10 ans. Donc avec la
professionnalisation du métier, c'est
comment on imagine
la protection, comment reconnaître
l'intérêt potentiellement public du job
de ha à cœur si on redort et si on
reprend la terminologie historique RFC
93 qui était la première fois que sur un
papier tech qu'on avait voilà ce que
veut dire à cœur contrairement à
Fricerur et j'en passe même si ça a été
galvodé entre-temps.
Donc on sent qu'il y a une approche mais
derrière c'est vachement intéressant ce
que tu dis parce que il y a il faut que
votre implication soit plus politique
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on est face à
un paradoxe. Le hackur
avec l'idéologie avec laquelle j'ai
grandi. Alors peut-être qu'elle est
biaisée, c'est euh on me donne un truc,
on me donne une boîte de Lego et
effectivement je l'ouvre, je jette le
manuel et je vais faire autre chose que
ce qu'on attend de moi qu'au lieu de
construire la bagnole, ça va être une
machine à laver. Voilà. Euh, comment
j'arrive à
Tu commences comme ça, après tu fais des
missiles.
C'est tout la problématique
avec une machine à laver. Si je mets un
parpad, je peux en faire une arme hein.
Mais
et il y a volet 6 et le côté
anticonformiste du hacking. Comment on
l'applique dans une conjecture politique
? Je me suis
Je t'ai pas dit d'être politiquement
correct. Ah oui, attention,
moi quand je te parle de quand quand je
vais te parler de politique, je suis pas
en train de te dire d'être politique
encore, je te dis simplement que vous
avez un savoir, vous avez un pouvoir,
c'est vous qui avez le route en fait des
serveurs de mail de l'Assemblée
nationale les gars. C'est c'est c'est
pas le député qui a ça, tu vois.
Euh donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
détenteur de la sécurité.
Voilà, c'est c'est pas quelque chose qui
est assimilé par les politiques. Alors,
c'est rigolo parce que tu parlais de
l'ANC. Effectivement, il y a eu un
énorme switch à l'ANC. Euh ben depuis
Poupard en fait, depuis Guillaume
Poupar,
agence nationale de la sécurité des
systèmes d'information, c'est notre
gendarme étatique Poup. Euh, il faut en
dire que du bien ici. Est-ce que je
ne peux pas en dire de mal si tu veux.
J'aimais pas trop son prédécesseur.
Oua, c'est pour ça que je te dis qu'il y
a eu il y a vraiment eu en fait un truc
dingue qui s'est passé sous son mandat
qui a été une ouverture aux communautés
en règle générale et l'ENC s'est mise à
communiquer.
Ce simple message d'expliquer que la
sécurité c'est c'est le problème la
cybersécurité c'est le problème de tout
le monde au quotidien.
Ça a été un truc enfin vraiment
important. Enfin, c'était la première
fois où tu as une instance de l'État euh
qui expliquait qu'en gros, ben voilà, ça
non seulement ça concerne tout le monde,
mais en plus de ça, on va mettre en
place des actions. Donc au niveau des
entreprises, au niveau des particuliers,
au niveau des entreprises, ils vont
aller former des gens, ils vont faire,
tu vois, du du data recovery ou des
choses, enfin de la remise en marche des
systèmes d'information quand quand il y
a eu un gros hack ou des trucs comme ça,
ils vont faire énormément de prévention
et pas que pour des grosses boîtes. Tu
as des antennes locales, c'est c'est un
truc qui est assez peu connu, mais tu as
des antennes locales avec des gens de DC
qui vont former des entreprises. Il
était temps.
Et ben ouais, mais tu vois quand tu vois
le nombre de postes quand tu vois le
nombre de postes ouverts
et euh je dirais les problématiques de
recrutement et de constitution de
ressources parce que l'accélération je
la situe à peu près 2016-27.
Ouais.
Donc pendant les élections la période
Wana Cry
ça a fait j'ai l'impression
expliquer faut expliquer Wana Cry.
Donc le fameux rançon logiciel
avant avant avant W, il on a eu aussi I
love you.
plus vieux
c'était un warm c'était
c'était notre pétal le le
contemporain de Way des des virus très
très méchants Wana Cry parce que c'était
les nord coréens qui avaient récupéré de
l'armement américain de la NS direct
après
pour pour faire un un méga run
someomeware
qui dieu merci avait une énorme faille
qui a été c'est Renault qui l'a
euh je sais plus je C'est un français
qui l' français qui a réussi à
je croisétait sur
il y avait un truc pour désactiver one
cry. Je crois que c'était en prenant un
nom de domaine. Il a acheté un nom de
domaine.
C'est kill switch effectivement de Way.
Il a acheté le nom de domaine pour moi
il est pas français.
Donc il a pas français français.
J'ai pas souvir ce soit.
Je me souviens plus qui qui était enfin
il y a le hackur miraculeux qui est
arrivé qui a désactivé une attaque
mondiale monstrueuse en claquant des
doigts et qui qui qui a sauvé milliard.
du rendre des comptes mais mais malgré
tout qui qui a sauvé la fesse de de
milliers d'entreprises à travers la
planète touché un radi à mon avis
euh
non mais il est il est devenu célèbre et
je pense qu'il a réussi quand même
malgré tout à à tirer partie de de ce
qui est un véritable exploit où il a
vraiment sauvé la vie des milliers
d'entreprises et puis il y a notre pétia
où là c'est les russes qui ont n'ont pas
fait un run someomware ils ont fait un
truc qui est s'apparenté un runomware
qui était planqué dans un logiciel de
comptat ukrainien que la plupart part
des boîtes ukrainiennes utilisées pour
déclarer leurs impôts et qui effacaient
le disque dur des boîtes ukrainiennes et
ça ça a eu des d'un impact financier
colossal détourné hein
mer a perdu pas loin du 800 millions
c'est son bons saint pareil pas loin
d'un milliard renaud a eu tout son tout
était en rade pas que sur les pays de l'
débordé sur toute
tous les systèmes de Renault donc ça ça
a coûté des milliards et 10 milliards et
c'était vraiment l'équivalent du bombe
atomique mais strictement dans le cyber
donc c'est vrai que ça a été des
événements super marquants aussi bien
pour des mecs comme moi qui ont raconté
parce que c'est très rigolo à raconter
que pour le monde de la cyber en général
où là ça a été branle bas de combat, on
mobilise tout ça, il faut faire
participer la société civile enfin la
société civile au sens de la communauté
à cœur parce qu'il va falloir qu'on ait
des des ressources disponibles en cas de
crise rapidement donc il faut qu'on
qu'on établisse des relations et ça a
radicalement changé la l'ANC d'une façon
plus générale et c'est aussi contempor
l'émergence des plateformes Bug Bounty
la l'image des hackurs dans la société
civile
il était temps. Mrot a aussi pas mal
contribuer à ça euh
schizophrénique paranoïque au passage.
Ouais mais quand même malgré tout tu as
l'école de la cryptoanarchie ou c'est
vrai que il est plutôt discutable he
b c'est peut-être moi qui a un petit
billet positif sur la cryptonarchie
parce qu'il chassait les péau et tu
adores les gens qui chass
mais ça tous les hackeurs chassent les
péos c'est c'est c'est la base de on
vous dit
c'est la base de de la philosophie
hackur les péos sont le le le mal
incarné tout tout hackur se doit de
chasser les pédos on rebondit là-dessus
mais quand il y a eu les premières
législations sur les les pédux ils sont
venus s'enterrer très profondément et
heureusement qu'il y avait la cœur élevé
quoi.
Ouais ouais ouais.
Écoute moi le premier souvenir que j'ai
de de campagne antipédo mené alors par
des hackurs à l'époque c'est une c'est
un grand mot c'était ça devait être à
l'époque pas à l'époque ICQ justement
c'était contre un
est tout le temps toi
ouais c'était contre un Ouais c'était
vraiment début des années 2000
alors c'est c'est bien avant alors
c'est même avant les années 2000 c'était
avant ouais çait ouais 96 95 96
peut-être Ouais. Euh c'était dirigé
contre un hébergeur néerlandais qui
s'appelle Lis Web et qui abritait pas
mal de contenu pédocriminel
et et les mecs ne voulaient pas couper
en fait si tu veux. Enfin et il y a eu
les prémisses, ce qu'on peut appeler un
DD un DDOS quoi. Euh
on parle pas souvent on parle pas
souvent du stress post-traumatique des
Hunters qui allent qui allent chasser
là-dedans.
Ah non mais ouais ouais.
Alors oui, mais ça tu vas le retrouver à
plein de niveaux si tu veux. Enfin,
si tu veux rajouter un mot.
Non, non, je je laisse finir mais
les donc ouais, si tu veux là le le truc
qui qui avait été fait assez simple. À
l'époque, tu avais un vieux truc de base
qui est très connu qui qui est devenu
assez mythique, s'appelait le Ping of
Death sur sur Windows qui était une
petite commande que il y a un paquet et
puis le Windows en face, pouf, il
crachait.
H à l'époque, il y avait pas de de gros
systèmes d'hébergement qui tournaient
sur autre chose que soit des des
versions très rudimentaires de de de
Linux, voire certains gros Unix mais
pour de du gros hébergement, non. Donc
tu avais quand même pas mal de Windows
euh pour tout ce qui était tu vois
hébergement, on va dire grand public
pour le toutvenant quoi. Et euh et donc
je crois que la première campagne
effectivement ça a été euh c'est l'un
des premiers gros desdos citoyens entre
guillemets
15. Ouais, je je saurais plus te donner
la date si j'étais jeune. En tout cas,
je compléterai parce que là, c'est
effectivement un scénario où il y a une
dynamique de volonté de recherche, de
démantellement ou de parasitage.
Paralyser les réseaux et les
infrastructures et neutralisation des
infrastructures pédocriminelles.
Euh des fois, c'est sans volonté directe
d'identification.
Euh il nous est déjà arrivé de subir la
situation et de la découvrir dans une
autre conjecture. J'ai un exemple qui me
vient en tête. Euh donc un client qui
subit donc un acte de cybercriminalité,
on déclenche ce qu'on appelle une
réponse à incident. Donc c'est le mode
pompier, on y va et puis on fait un état
des lieux de la situation, on
l'accompagne pour reconstruire son
système d'information et puis il y a
tout un processus d'investigation
numérique comme lorsqu'on a atteint d'un
virus. Si je prends l'analogie du Covid,
on va essayer de trouver ce qu'on
appelle le patient zéro, donc le le nœud
numéro 1 de la chaîne d'infection, donc
la porte d'entrée des cybercriminels
pour propager la souche virale et
infecter tout le système d'information.
Donc on fait le travail d'investigation
numérique et sur le poste du patient
zéro, on retrouve des traces de
compromission. Puis généralement, c'est
des postes qu'on auxquels on soumet des
analyses poussées. Et puis là, dans le
cadre d'une réponse à incident, tout ce
qui est de plus traditionnel, tu
commences à tomber sur des noms de
fichiers où tu te dis bon bah là OK,
visiblement il avait des lubis
collaborateur pendant ses heures de
travail sur du contenu à caractère
pornographique puis tu commences à
tomber sur des mots clés ou c'est le FBI
qui fournit une liste d'ailleurs sur
leur site quand tu veux quand tu as pas
le contenu ou tu veux pas visionner le
contenu pour ton rapport et le mettre
dans le rapport de mots clés bien
spécifiques par rapport à des déviances
sexuelles.
qui permet de confirmer que c'est du
contenu à caractère pédopornographique
juste avec le nom du fichier des
abréviations en fait on voit pas les
données.
C'est en allemand
des ter anglais ou
et ça tu vois c'est le genre de
situation qui nous est arrivé dans une
conjecture de réponse à incident
technique. tu tombes là-dessus et là tu
te retrouves comple dans le sens où tu
dis bah on a un métier d'expertise
technique, notre métier c'est de réparer
de la machine, d'accompagner le client
sur un volet
social humain parce que c'est quand même
un traumatisme pour eux lorsqu'ils
subissent un acte de cybercriminalité
que tu as la moitié au chômage
technique. Enfin bref, j'en passe. Et
puis là tu dis "Ah ouais, on se retrouve
confronté à ce genre de dossier et puis
une machine juridique derrière où tu
prends la peine de constituer un
livrable dédié aux autorités compétentes
pour dénoncer la situation. et pas
planter l'investigation
et pas planter l'investigation et qui
aboutira sur un non lieu parce
qu'effectivement il s'agit il s'agit
d'un individu isolé et que par rapport à
la manière dont sont chargées les
équipes qui diligentes au volet
juridique judiciaire cette typologie
d'enquête qui vont te répondre et de
manière assez aberrente bah non c'est un
individu nous on travaille plus sur des
réseaux de 100 1000 personnes et on
cherche à démanteler du réseau. En fait
ça quand tu le subis à titre humain déjà
tu ressens une frustration folle par
rapport à l'injustice la situation mais
là c'est totalement subjectif et c'est
là aussi où tu te fais la remarque sur
le volet psychologique de ah mais en
fait on a rien en place et puis qui va
expliquer où rassurer l'équipe sur les
spécificités de ce qu'on est susceptible
de découvrir dans notre métier sachant
que on sait pas ce qu'on va découvrir.
Je prends l'exemple de la
pédocriminalité.
Il nous est déjà arrivé sur
l'investigation numérique sur tomber sur
de sur le fait de tomber sur du sur du
contenu à caractère orienté terrorisme
ou des choses comme ça. Et même chose
c'est du contenu qui est lourd euh
visuellement, graphiquement.
Alors ça c'est un truc qu'on a fait sur
c'est un truc qu'on a fait sur reflet
effectivement et
ça ça s'improvise pas en fait. Et c'est
un p de notre métier qu'on découvre sur
le tas, sur le terrain.
Et la la vraie difficulté c'est tu dois
garder la face face au client parce que
c'est lui que tu es censé rassurer. Mais
toi tu dis mais je gère comment la
situation ? On n pas été formé au même
titre que bon maintenant c'est plus le
cas mais notre métier on l'a appris sur
le tas, on l'a appris pour beaucoup de
manière bricolée. C'est en train de
changer le volet psychologique quand on
échange avec les écoles, c'est vachement
intéressant de voir que il est pas
forcément abordé avec les étudiants. À
la rigueur, ce qu'on retrouve de plus
abordé, ça c'est déjà une progression,
c'est les notions d'éthique et de moral.
pour éviter que déjà ne serait-ce que
pendant leur cursus postback pour ceux
qui souhaitent se former à ces métiersl
ne soient tenté par des dérives
autour de l'argent de l'ego et
potentiellement passer du du côté obscur
de la force si on fait
voilà avec une vision de l'éthique et le
respect de la loi et l'éthique et la loi
c'est deux choses distinctes. Donc c'est
là où on voit qu'il y a encore des
chantiers de fonds à aller travailler où
là on parle même pas de technique, on
parle de
de valeur éthique morale et derrière
aussi c'est quit de la légalité de ces
opérations flash entre guillemets parce
que aujourd'hui de traquer du
pédocriminel sur internet euh il y a la
notion de faire justice soi-même. Donc
même chose dans la constitution et la
restitution de la preuve numérique
auprès des autorités compétentes. des
marchés sur des œufs parce que quand on
t'échange avec les avocats
potentiellement toi en tant que
qu'investigateur numérique indépendant,
tu peux biaiser la preuve. Si tu biaises
la preuve, tu peux créer un vise de
procédure. Donc même chose àoutir sur un
résultat le coût de l'erreur sur
l'attribution, c'est
le coût de l'erreur sur l'attribution,
tu peux çaut ça coûte une vie.
Enfin, tu ruines une vie littéralement.
Donc il y a toutes ces variables là dans
l'équation aujourd'hui quel cadre on
amène et est-ce que finalement parce que
il y a un constat c'est nos autorités
compétentes sont sous staafé même si
équipé sous staafé et pas accompagné
psychologiquement alors que c'est un
métier qui est atroce. On a eu des cas,
on a eu un cas et je laisserai la parole
là parce que je suis bavard, un cas d'un
Ntech, donc brigade d'investigation
numérique, je sais plus c'est rattaché à
la gendarmerie,
qui est venu Nova en disant "On reçoit
un PC d'une saisie,
euh on a un bitlocker dessus donc
bitlocker technologie Windows permettant
de chiffrer le contenu du disque dur.
Alors de manière plus ou moins sécurisée
en fonction du mode dont Bitlocker a été
configuré. Et de toute manière chez eux,
le postulat est simple. Alors ça remonte
à 2021 il est où ?
Je reçois un poste bitlcker. Je n'ai pas
été formé. Le poste, il repart dans les
saisies. Il y a pas d'investigation
numérique qui est diligenté dessus.
Alors je ne dis pas que certains
services ne savent pas le faire. Là on
parlait d'un NTE dans un service plutôt
régional que sur les grandes sur les
grands sur les grands groupements plutôt
sur la région parisienne ou autres. Mais
quand on entend ce genre de concert
alors comment est-ce que les équipes
about les les enquêtes aboutissent ?
parce que je prends du réseau criminel
enfin sur le maillon faible
du encro chat du encro chat on était sur
le niveau encore au-dessus ils ont
réussi à introduire ces réseaux-là mais
là quand on voit une enquête où il
reçoiv le bit le PC il repart il y a
rien qui est fait dessus dit ah ouais il
y a quelque chose à faire mais qui les
forme
alors après il est possible que il était
mis de côté jusqu'au jour en fait où on
aura le zé de qui va bien faire un truc
ah non mais les les solutions techniques
c'est ça l'horreur c'est qu'elles
existent
bien mais leur il a pas déjà été ouvert.
Tu as alors si on commence à rentrer un
peu dans le détail technique, tu as TPM
pin et TPM plus pin. En gros, c'est
différentes surcouches de de chiffrement
de ton disque. Il y en a un qui va
chiffrer ton disque de base et c'est
dans une puce stockée sur la carte mère
que le déchiffrement se fait. Donc
potentiellement, tu chopes le disque
dur, tu le branches sur un autre PC, tu
peux pas récupérer la la donnée en clair
dessus. Ensuite, il y a du pin, donc
c'est le fameux écran bleu dès que tu
démarres ton PC où là tu as le code et
après le déchiffrement se fait et après
tu as le combo TPN plus pin qui sur le
papier est le plus sécurisé. Mais
effectivement à l'époque, on avait déjà
eu cet échange. Il y avait des
techniques d'attaque avec du des petits
équipements électroniques sur la carte
mère à brancher qui permettait de
récupérer les la clé secrète, donc
permettre un aboutissement du
déchiffrement du disque. Euh, il y a
d'autres attaques qui ont été présentées
par un chercheur italien ou espagnol à
vérifier. il a fait une conférence à
Brest il y a 2 ans
où il avait trouvé 3 qu CVE sur
cette technologie là pour arriver
toujours à récupérer les clés de
chiffrement. Une fois de plus, ces
travaux de recherche aboutissent sur
internet de manière gracieuse. C'est pas
de la ressource qui est commercialisée
par une structure. Il y a des ressources
commercialisées par des boîtes
spécialisées en récupération de données,
des verrouillages d'Android, d'iPhone et
j'en passe. Mais sur ces exploitsci,
on les trouve sur Google ou sur GitHub
qui sont des plateformes qui regroupent
des projets ou des bout de codes
téléchargeables
par n'importe qui
pour l'intérêt général. C'est ça. Mais
ils n'ont pas été formés à les utiliser.
Et lorsqu'on leur parle, c'est avant
j'étais gendarme avant de me retrouver à
Ntech, le cursus qui nous était décrit,
c'est j'ai fait une licence de 18 mois
de monté en compétence
et j'avais un boîtier made in Israël sur
lequel je pouvais brancher n'importe
quel téléphone et qui qui donne lock.
C'est c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
très clairement.
Donc là, tu dis bah on fait quoi pour
demain ? Parce que dans le jeu du chat
et de la souris, c'est très bien. Bon
ben, il y a peut-être l'intérêt public
citoyen des hackurs qui finalement est
timidement reconnu un petit peu bancal.
comment le structure et là je te rejoins
sur le volet politiser la alors
politiser politiquement correct pas
forcément mais essayer d'avoir une
approche politique
plus institutionnalisable
mais pour le peu d'échanges que j'ai pu
avoir avec nos représentants politiques
que ce soit au niveau députés euh ou
ministre notamment côté numérique et pas
forcément là ministre actuel mais même
les anciens on a l'impression qu'il y a
il y a deux mondes qui se rend compte
Oh oui Et euh et effectivement, il y a
le cliché de tu débarques ensuite à
capuche face à quelqu'un qui est en
costard. Alors là, on n clairement pas
dans le politiquement correct, mais
avec toute la forme et politesse de
tirer la sonnette d'alarme en disant euh
on se connaît pas euh mais néanmoins en
tant que concitoyen euh je pense que on
n'est pas je suis pas le seul quand je
fais ce genre de démarche. D'autres ont
dû le faire
de dire il y a une problématique de fond
qu'il va falloir résoudre et cette
problématique de fond
se elle se discute et elle se débriefe
avec une journée calée, pas avec des
amendements complexes où quand je prends
le support référentiel en 432 pages,
j'enlève déjà 200 pages de alinea
pour fluidifier la lecture du texte mais
de rentrer concrètement sur des cas
d'école et se dire est-ce que vous avez
conscience de l'existence de ceci ? Et
ça, j'ai l'impression que c'est l'étape
d'après. Mais comment le déclencher ? Il
il y a des interlocuteurs de valable
dans dans le personnel politique. On les
compte sur le doig de la main, mais il y
en a quelques-uns qui sont valables. Il
faut pas y aller en 10. C'est c'est
quand tu vas à l'assemblée, tu peux ne
pas mettre une cravate, mais à minima,
tu mets une veste et une chemise. Euh,
tu fais du hacking social.
Tu fais un peu de hacking social. Il y a
au mieux de tout ce petit monde des gens
qui sont pas forcément compétents mais
qui malgré tout ont envie de comprendre
et on sont de bonne foi.
Euh donc il y a il y a de quoi établir
ça et d'ailleurs les vieux comme nous
seront ravis de de faire les mises en
les mises en relation. Euh c'est pas
désespéré mais il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de travail à faire et puis il y
a cette institutionnalisation qui est
que aujourd'hui ça repose sur quelques
bonnes volonté pas sur une institution
pas sur quoi que ce soit. J'essaie pas
de faire une généralité, mais je me dis
que même s'il y a effectivement quelques
individus qui se comptent sur le doigt
d'une main, derrière une fois que la
passation d'information est faite,
finalement on rentre dans une dans une
mécanique politique où c'est eux-mêmes
qui se retrouvent à toute petite échelle
à essayer de convaincre
et d'expliquer ça au plus grand nombre.
Et j'ai l'impression que c'est un de une
deè c'est pire que ça c'est qu'au sein
d'un même groupe parlementaire tu vas
avoir un ou deux députés qui vont se
retrouver en confrontation direct avec
un texte que son propre groupe est en
train de présenter.
Hm.
C'est euh
au sein d'un même groupe parlementaire,
tu vas avoir un marchand d'armes qui est
député.
Ça, on l'a vu avec Nice 2
et euh des gens qui essayent très
sincèrement de faire progresser le monde
de la cybersécurité. Ils sont dans le
même groupe parlementaire, ils siègent
en même temps.
Et sachant que ceux qui gagnent seront
ceux qui auront les solutions
Ah ben c'est le marchand d'ar qui gagne.
C'est ceux qui auront les solutions les
plus pourries notamment sur la censure,
sur le tu vois le le le système de d'âge
d'identification et tout ça. C'est ceux
qui auront le la réponse la plus
simpliste qui est bah vous voyez le
contrôle d'âge, c'est normal, il faut
contrôler l'âge des gens.
Euh oui, sauf que c'est pas l'âge des
enfants que tu es en train de contrôler,
c'est l'âge de toute la population. H
donc
mais en général pour dire ce genre de
conneries, tu en trouves un qui comprend
absolument rien la technique et ils vont
pas te mettre Botorelle pour défendre un
truc. Princip oui. Voilà, tu t'envoies
au feu la personne qui comprend le moins
mais qui va être très très convaincu de
ce qu'elle fait.
C'est le Firewall Windows. J'ai
c'est Oui. Ou c'est le logiciel de
sécurisation Adopi, c'est le enfin voilà
c'est open office le firewall open
office, c'est tous ces trucs là. Oui oui
mais c'est important parce que quand
quand des face à des gens comme ça nous
on se heurte à des murs, on est
incapable d'expliquer quoi que ce soit
alors que il y a des gens qui
comprennent très très bien ce qu'on dit
à l'assemblée mais c'est pas eux qu'on
choisi pour faire passer des lois c'est
ça qui fait les blackat c'estàd à force
de pas être connu à force de se faire
cracher dessus à force d'être sous-payé
à force de d'être considéré
à force de perdre confiance dans la race
humaine. Si je fais un retour
d'expérience avec ma génération parce
que je pense qu'il y a de nouveau un
enjeu.
Je te réponds après. Je finis ma phrase
et je triche après. Trop bon avec moi.
Tu es trop bon.
Euh je peux pas répondre de manière
exhaustive et j'aurais pas cette
pertinence là. Euh je vais le faire avec
ma fenêtre temporelle et mon âge. Euh je
suis sorti d'un d'un bac+ 2 en 2014.
J'ai trouvé mon premier job en tant que
6 admin. Euh donc à l'époque, je
postulais auprès des entreprises. Donc
c'était avant ce revirement de on change
les politiques RH, on se met à recruter
des hackur, on fait moins attention au
diplôme. Euh j'étais au chômage, j'étais
au chômage. Donc j'ai eu le temps de
m'autoformer pendant quelques dizaines
de milliers d'heures pendant 2 ans
d'érance professionnelle.
La meilleure école
et je postule en tant que 6 admin en
disant de toute manière, je veux pas
rester 6 admin. Ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est de faire de la séc. À l'époque bah
j'avais pas le diplôme donc je postulais
avec un rapport d'audit pour chaque
structure gratuit.
Euh alors c'était c'était dangereux.
Oui.
Non, c'était dangereux. Et
l'amirorée non, tu l'as eu.
Tu l'as eu l'amiricoré ?
J'ai eu quelques ennuis historiques
après compris des proportions telles que
les siennes. Non. Donc je j'ai
visiblement une bonne étoile. Euh mais
au-delà de ça, oui, effectivement
aujourd'hui, on peut le faire de manière
plus constructive et sans avoir recours
à ce genre d'extrêmeci. Mais à l'époque
dans la communauté
dans ma tranche d'âge avec laquelle j'ai
changé dans cette période d'érance
professionnelle euh bah j'ai continué à
bosser, j'ai continué à apprendre
jusqu'à avoir cette chance
professionnelle et mais il fallait une
forme de résilience. Cette résilience
bah elle m'est propre, elle est liée à
l'éducation que j'ai reçue par mes
parents.
Donc ça veut dire que je peux comprendre
ce qu'on enfin je le dis souvent, je
peux comprendre ceux qui ont fait le
choix de basculer du côté illégalité.
attractivité de la gratification
financière qu'on peut en tirer.
Je n'excuse pas pour autant parce que
c'était une question de patience et si
j'avais fait ce choix là, j'aurais eu
l'impression de cracher dans la soupe
dans le sens où
respect à tes parents ? Euh alors
respect à mes parents d'une part et
respect je reviens au père que j'évoqué
tout à l'heure, c'est ceux qui se sont
embêtés pendant euh plus de 10 ans à
permettre la légifération de mon job.
Euh bah j'avais le ressenti d'avoir le
devoir de passer le flambeau au plus
jeune. Donc si je fais ce choix de
facilité,
finalement je vais tirer enfin oui
cracher dans la soupe ou me tirer une
balle dans le pied ou déconstruire et
donner une mauvaise image des efforts
précédents parce que ces conduites de
changement elles prennent des années en
fait elles font pas du jour au lendemain
et plus je vieillis plus je le vois.
Quand je vois que pour faire passer
enfin pour transposer un texte de loi
qui explique qu'il faudrait peut-être
qu'on arrête de faire des bêtises depuis
20 ans sur la manière dont on développe
des logiciel dans 90 % des boîtes à
l'échelle nationale et je parle je sors
même pas sur l'Europe ni à l'échelle
mondiale que ça prend des années déjà à
rédiger, à transposer, à appliquer, à
avoir des sanctions qui sont réellement
opérationnelles et qu'on se rend compte
que la conduite de changement elle se
fait sur 10 ans. On comprend ce que ça
veut dire un peu plus le mot résilience.
Euh mais bon, ça c'est peut-être sagesse
de vieux con qui arrive d'année en année
et je pense que c'est important à avoir
en tête dès qu'on commence sinon on peut
vite se faire tenter.
Il est bien le petit hein.
Ah ben ça redonne fo l'humanité hein.
C'est clair. Tu crois qu'on a fait venir
de BR pour rien
déconn parce qu'il y a il y a les côtes
de port qui vont cramer.
D'accord.
Euh j'ai puis j'ai quelques questions de
la de la de la communauté. Je voudrais
juste
5 minutes.
La France ouf fait pas écouté par les
gens qui ont les mains dans le
cambouille.
Zone de guerre, guerre intelligence
économique guerre économique prédation
de la Chine, de la Russie, du Qatar, de
tout le monde sur nous, sur nos boîtes,
donc sur notre économie et infiné sur le
nombre de chômeurs de violence aux
personnes et ainsi de suite. Vous la
sentez comment l'avenir là ? On va
commencer par le vieux, le moins vieux.
Et
non, c'est c'est lui, il est plus jeune
que moi.
Ah le jeu en premier.
Vas-y. Le jeu.
Ah, moi je sens très très mal. Euh je
pense qu'on
ta retraite.
Bah, elle sera pas en France euh
sera payé ou sera pas payé ?
Non, elle sera pas payé. Ça c'est une
pyramide de pontier les retraites.
Bon, allez
euh
je pense qu'il y a deux menaces
qui planent au-dessus de la France sous
forme de guerre.
Il y a la guerre tant espérée de du
gouvernement actuel qui est de d'aller
se friter avec les Russes.
Non, tu peux pas dire ça. Les Russes
sont agresseurs, ils ont leur lecture.
Alors
et grosso modo l'inscription de tout un
courant en Europe qui est de voir son
avenir dans une confrontation avec la
Russie. Peu importe qui agressi, c'est
vraiment de dresser
peu importe.
Non non mais c'est on a quand même des
gouvernants qui aujourd'hui
le clingon qui fait chier. Bah ouais, il
y a la Fédération en face.
Voilà. Et et alors qui a provoqué leon ?
Ça, on sait pas. C'est c'est pas
vraiment le souci. Le souci, c'est qu'on
on dresse euh à toute une génération
euh une perspective d'avenir qui est de
faire la guerre. Euh et
tu parles quelle guerre ? La guerre vrai
vraie pampan ou la guerre économique ?
Non, non, non. La vra la vraie guerre
pan euh fus par proxy et la vraie guerre
pan euh avec tout ce que ça implique de
complètes reconversion de notre
économie, de notre système politique euh
de notre système médiatique dans un
système destiné à faire la guerre
et de notre système informatique de
passer de notre système de tout de tout
vraiment de passer vers euh une économie
de guerre, euh des médias de guerre euh
une société de guerre euh et on peut
dire adieu à la démocratie au passage.
Et puis il y a un autre menace qui est
tout aussi guerrière qui est une guerre
civile euh qui est aussi une très très
grosse menace pour pour la France.
D'autant plus que les Russes sont pas
idiots, ils savent très bien que la
meilleure façon d'éviter de se
confronter une guerre avec l'Europe,
c'est peut-être que l'Europe s'effonde
sur elle-même et on voit des signes très
forts.
Trump a joue la même carte, hein.
Tout à fait, tout à fait, tout à fait.
Non, Trump Trump n'est pas la solution.
Euh mais malgré tout, pour revenir à
notre petit précaré européen, on voit
quand même des prémisses de guerre
civile un peu partout. Euh et donc on on
est entre guerre civile ou guerre tout
court. Je vois pas vraiment d'autres
issu si ce n'est l'exil. Euh donc c'est
c'est
les perspectives à mon sens pas bonnes
du tout. D'autant plus que
fondamentalement on a vendu le pays aux
Américains en
pas que aux Amér non, on a vendu le pays
à qui l'on voulait et qui faisait un
chèque. Mais d'un point de vue
infrastructure informatique pour rester
dans notre précarré, c'est
essentiellement aux Américains qu'on a
vendu le pays en imag en faisant une
confusion totale entre les amis
démocrates et les Américains.
Je je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Tu dis qu'on a vendu le pays aux
Américains mais on s'est simplement
rapproché de celui qui allait mieux nous
protéger contre les rouges.
On s'est rapproché des démocrates.
Oui.
En en oubliant complètement que c'était
aussi une démocratie qui pouvait du jour
au lendemain décider de voter pour
quelqu'un d'autre. Euh, on a une
première alerte qui était le premier
mandat de Trump que tout le monde
s'était forcé de considérer comme une
parenthèse et on allait oublier et la la
réalité c'est que c'est pas du tout une
parenthèse, c'est une direction prenne
les États-Unis et malgré tout on le on
leur a vendu le pays. Donc aujourd'hui,
ils nous tiennent par les couilles. Tout
d'un coup, les testicules, tout d'un
coup la la souveraineté numérique qui a
un violot de mer
auquel on tient depuis très longtemps
est devenu quelque chose de totalement
primordial parce que tous ces couillons
réalisent que les boîtes américaines
sont assujettes à l'État américain. ce
qu'on aurait pu réaliser à l'époque de
Snowden à minima et que bah les grosses
boîtes américaines, même les plus
démocrate façon Google, malgré tout
obéissent à l'État américain, servent
les intérêts américains qui ne sont pas
du tout les nôtres. Et on se retrouve
dans une situation qui est à la limite
de désespéré. Là, je pense qu'on on peut
espérer dans les années qui viennent
reconquérir un peu de souveraineté
numérique sur des domaines totalement
primordiaux. Je pense à l'armée
notamment, mais pour des pas entiers,
c'est fini. C'est c'est foutu. Il va
falloir qu'on fasse avec le fait qu'on
ait une colonie que en terme notamment
sur l'opinion publique et les réseaux
sociaux, on est une colie numérique sur
les infrastructures, sur le cloud,
mais sur un truc qui est totalement
sensible et qui qui rend paranoïac tous
les politiques qui sont les réseaux
sociaux et les fameuses ingérences. On
est un gouvernerat. Le le DSA, c'est un
une tentative d'établir un gouvernerat
dans une colonie,
un gouver un protectorat,
un petit gouverneur local qui serait
Macron en France et d'autres dans
différentes colonies américaines sur le
continent européen, mais ça reste une
colonie américaine. L'opinion publique
ces 10 dernières années s'est transposé
des médias vers les réseaux sociaux.
En France, on a une situation médiatique
qui est catastrophique. On est parmi les
moins crédibles de de l'ensemble des
nations sur lequel on peut mesurer ça
avec les États-Unis d'ailleurs et la
Corée du Sud. Il y a à peu près un/art
de la population qui aujourd'hui
considère que ce qui lisent dans les
médias c'est la vérité. C'est pour ça
qu'il faut diversifier les sources
d'information, trianguler l'information
reflet si tu si tu triangules ton
information, ce qui est très sain à
faire, tu vas trouver ailleurs dans des
médias alternatifs sur les réseaux
sociaux des informations qui vont
contribuer à faire s'effondrer la
crédibilité des médias. Tu vas
t'apercevoir à quel point ils sont soit
totalement à côté de la plaque, soit ils
mentent. Et tout ça contribue à faire en
sorte que le théâtre de l'opinion
publique, c'est les réseaux sociaux. Ça
ça n'est plus un système vertical avec
les médias mis en place par Bernise
Edard Bernz au début du 20e siècle.
C'est aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux ça se passe. Ce qui veut dire
très concrètement que ça se passe aux
États-Unis et en Chine mais pas en
France.
Livre propaganda
propaganda de de d'Edouard Bernes qui
qui a un tout petit bouquin qui se lit
assez facilement et qui permettra de
comprendre qu'est-ce que c'est que le
fameux système politico-médiatique.
C'est c'est pas un théorie conspit quoi
que ce soit. C'est un truc qui a été
théorisé au début du 20e siècle, qui a
amené les États-Unis à s'impliquer dans
la Première Guerre mondiale et qui a
défini ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
communication, relation publique,
marketing. Tout ça a été posé en base au
début du 20e siècle. Et si vous voulez
comprendre comment on en est arrivé à la
fin de ce monde là et au début du monde
des réseaux sociaux et à CamJica qui est
un peu l'équivalent mais
Cambridganaitica
Comitica
Magouille très sophistiqué de comment
manipuler l'opinion publique à partir de
données personnelles en individualisant
les les messages là où propaganda c'est
un message pour l'ensemble de la
population qui passe par des masses
médias. Aujourd'hui, on passe plus du
tout par des masses médias qu'on de
moins en moins d'influence. On passe par
les réseaux sociaux avec des messages
ultra individualisés,
ciblé
ciblés voter pour pour
pour plein de choses, pour te vendre des
idées. Pour te vendre des idées d'une
façon générale, des idées qui vont te
réjouir, qui vont t'énerver, qui vont te
faire t'opposer, qui vont te faire ce
que peu importe, on va te manipuler à
travers de l'émotion qu'on va te
déclencher de façon à t'amener à faire
quelque chose, voter ou autre chose, peu
importe, mais t'amener à faire quelque
chose. Et on est on est passé du monde
d'Edouard Ber du 20e siècle au monde des
réseaux sociaux de façon très brutale en
quelques années avec des politiques qui
n'y comprennent rien et qui aujourd'hui
se contentent de tourner en boucle sur
les ingérences russes, les ingérences
alors qu'il y a au moins une douzaine de
nations qui sont en ingérance quasi
permanente sur le territoire français et
que les Russes sont vraiment l'arbre qui
cache la forêt. Le problème c'est
c'est pas les meilleurs
et c'est loin d'être les meilleurs. Par
contre, si si là où ils sont excellents,
c'est que ils vont prendre ils vont
prendre trois bulgares, ils vont leur
distribuer quelques centaines d'euros
pour aller acheter des têtes de cochon
ou un pot de peinture.
Pas des serbes. Non, c'était peut-être
pas des serbes.
Non,
les bugargards, je crois que c'était les
cercueils.
Ouais, les buggars les étoiles ble
c'était les étoiles bleues et les pots
de peinture sur les synagogues une
opération avec probablement 1000 ou 2000
balles de dépensé de la part du FSB qui
va donner 500 articles de presse parce
que la presse adore ça. Et donc au
final, il faut se mettre à la place des
Russes.
Crétin
si pour 1000 balles, tu déclenches une
opération de relation publique qui si tu
avais un RP que tu lançais un pot de
yaourturais coûté facilement 500000
balles, bah forcément tu vas continuer.
Ça va être les potercueils, ensuite ça
va être les étoiles bleues, ensuite ça
va être les pots de peinture vertes sur
les synagogues et demain ça sera une
autre connerie. Mais il serait
complètement idiot d'abandonner ce
concept dans la mesure où ça ne coûte
rien à faire et que ça une répercussion
médiatique phénoménale. Mais il faut pas
perdre de vue que pendant que les Russes
occupent la galerie et les médias, vous
avez une une douzaine d'autres nations
qui font des trucs beaucoup plus
subtils, euh beaucoup plus intelligents
et qui elles ont un réel impact sur
l'opinion publique. D'autant plus que
pour beaucoup, elles ont une diaspora et
donc elles ont des vrais relais locaux,
ce qui est pas vraiment le cas des rus.
Toutou.
Ouais, je pense qu'on va voir en fait
une fenêtre de tir, on va dire, allez,
de 5 à 7 ans euh dans laquelle le modèle
démocratique qu'on connaît nous ici et
même au niveau mondial va être va être
attaqué mais d'une manière en fait
jamais vue.
On va avoir le choix en fait entre
l'abandonner, donc ben céder au
totalitarisme,
soit se servir des outils qu'on a à
disposition, que sont internet, que sont
enfin les interactions sociales en règle
générale.
L'éducation nationale peut-être
l'éducation nationale, il va falloir
mettre un gros coup de peinture dessus
hein. C'est
c'est plus que de la peinture hein.
C'est Oui. Enfin, il y a déjà
il y a un problème d'investissement
manifeste, mais le problème c'est pas
que de donner du pognon, c'est aussi
former les personnels à euh
se réconcilier avec l'esprit critique.
Euh tu as dû voir les études d'ailleurs
qu'il y a eu sur le l'usage en fait des
I sur l'impact cognitif
qu'on les IA sur les les jeunes
générations.
Cette fenêtre de tir de 5 à 7 ans
correspond justement un petit peu à ça.
Si on arrive pas à structurer
rapidement, ça va être très très
compliqué
très moyen terme en fait. Et là, je te
passe vraiment tous les problèmes
budgétaires, tous les problèmes enfin
financiers de la France, de la dette, de
bidule
énergétique.
Énergétique, ça c'est un énorme
problème. C'est vraiment un énorme
problème. C'est Je sais que tu es très
attaché à la calorie. Euh c'est un
problème qui est terrible parce que ben
enfin on sait on n pas de plus
non je je parlais réellement par rapport
aux gens que tuinvite et c'est c'est un
thème qui revient de manière récurrent
votre clé de voûte
exactement enfin le il y a un truc qui
est très vrai et que plusieurs de tes
invités ont déjà signalé c'est que
l'économie c'est quoi c'est l'énergie
transformée donc si on n pas d'énergie
on a pas d'économie si on n pas
d'économie on sait plus faire nation si
on sait plus faire d'énergie on a pas de
parti socialistes
Si si on narrive plus à faire nation,
ben on cera de toute façon
d'otalitarisme d'une manière ou d'une
autre. Pas d'énergie, Macronie.
On a la la vraie question qu'on va
devoir se poser, si c'est si ce
totalitarisme sera le nôtre du souverain
du made in France ou si ça sera un
totalitarisme étranger.
C'est c'est la vraie question, la vraie
inconnu, elle est là. Mais le la l'état
de décrépitude de la démocratie, il est
aujourd'hui. C'est pas demain si on élit
je ne sais pas qui ça va. C'est
il faut plus croire à l'homme
providentiel.
L'article 8 de la de la déclaration de
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qui est la vie privée, il est en
train d'être mis à sac. On a évité le
pire avec chat contrôle mais il est en
train d'être mis à sac. L'article 10 de
la liberté d'expression, il est mis à
sac par le DSA. On a déjà attaqué deux
articles fondamentaux de ce qui fait la
base de nos démocraties en Europe. Euh
le suivant, ça sera probablement le le
le droit à l'asile politique. Euh et à
partir du moment où ces trois
articles-là ont sauté, alors non
seulement ceux qui vont gueuler le jour
où on attaquera le droit à l'asile
politique vont avoir l'air un peu con
d'avoir regardé ailleurs quand les deux
premiers se faisaient défoncer. Mais
c'est c'est il suffit de défoncer ces
deuxl et que tout l'édifice va
s'effondrer.
Mais à côté de ça, on a un beau GR RGPD
et des cookie wall, tu vois. Enfin
voilà, on est comme des cons à valider
nos cookies alors que [__] il y a le
feu à la baraque quoi. Les gars, quoi.
Bris, toi qui est jeune, toi qui a
encore plein d'avenir adieux devant toi
qui qui
Est-ce que j'ai encore de la résilience
après les avoir écouté ?
Je désolé. Non, non, mais
tu vas hériter de 3300 milliards de
dettes.
Alors là-dessus, je suis je suis je suis
je suis dans un déni et je vais répondre
que sur la partie cyber parce que il y a
déjà pas mal de choses à dire.
C'est tout à ton honneur.
Euh
je je rejoins le le discours autour de
la recrudescence de tout ce qui est acte
d'ingérence étrangère, des informations.
C'était quasiment un cadeau
d'anniversaire pour moi cette année
puisque c'était au mois d'avril. Le 29
avril a été officiellement reconnu et
proclamé sur la place publique la
reconnaissance des tentatives
d'ingérence russe à l'égard de la
France. Alors, je vais essayer de le
dire avec un bel accent parce que sinon
on va passer donc le le groupuscule
dénoncé c'est apt 28
euh
russe qui se dit goû
c'est Advance Persistant Freat donc
c'est l'un des n je crois qu'on est aux
alentours entre 150 et 200 groupuscules
identifiés qui porte le douom de Fancy
Bear parce que si je le dis avec un
mauvais accent ça fait fancy beer
ou ça
et c'est pas la même chose be
donc
qui sur lequel a été attribué Donc il y
a eu un principe d'attribution. On a
rattaché de l'ingérence historique qui
remonte déjà à plus de 10 ans. Donc
l'incident TV5 monde de l'ingérance sur
le pic de 2024 sur le nombre d'incidents
et de signalement traités. Donc toujours
dans le rapport de l'ANC en juillet 2024
donc pendant les Jo. C'était eux les
numéros d'urgence aussi ou pas ?
Euh je saurais pas te dire. J'ai trois
exemples en tête. Donc TV5 Monde les Joo
et plus récent ma mémoire vient de me
faire défaut. Euh
euh et bah les présidentiels 2017 tout
simplement.
Macron les Macron
et euh
Macron c'est le le verolage de Cédrico.
Oui. Un bon vieux fishing des familles.
Euh ça
hein de
Donc tu prends ces trois exemplesci.
Donc le plus récent étant les
Cédric Muniier Majoui.
Non non c'est Cédrico.
Ils sont plusieurs dans l'équipe à cette
féfier. Bah
vous dire il pas fait c'était pendant la
campagne. Non non mais on est c'est lui
qui avait communiqué notamment
là-dessus.
Tu prends ces trois exemples là et tu te
dis on est en avril 2025 et c'est à ce
moment-là que sur la place publique on
on déballe et on pointe enfin quelqu'un
du doigt sur un sujet d'ingérence
étrangère. J'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu comme si on on annonçait
publiquement quelque chose qu'on sait.
Alors, je ne fais pas que de
l'attribution vers la Russie puisque
c'est multiétatique et bidirectionnel,
tridirectionnel dans tous les sens
aujourd'hui parce que ça reste un enjeu
de connaissance d'espionnage industriel,
d'espionnage étatique dans le but de
savoir où on est finalement son voisin
peut-être géographique mais pas en terme
de proximité d'avis politique
et de basculement démocratique.
Voilà ce qui fait que
cette démarche là elle continuera et je
suis assez intiment donc là je prends
plus un pari sur l'avenir. Peut-être que
je me tromperai mais je le reconnaîtrai
humblement. Euh je me dis qu'aujourd'hui
chaque pays est en train de se
constituer une base d'armes numérique de
par la prise de conscience autour de ces
sujets-là. Euh que ces armes numériques
dans la manière si pour le peu
d'histoire qu'on m'a inculqué à l'école
ou sur la manière dont je me suis
intéressé sur les sujets autour de la
seconde guerre mondiale et de la
première guerre mondiale et ce qui en a
découlé sur l'arrivée du nucléaire. J'ai
je j'oserais peut-être prendre le paris
aujourd'hui de me dire que les plus
grosses armes numériques qui sont
susceptibles de déstabiliser un pays de
manière globale donc sur appel
historiquement non stocks net je
pourrais y revenir après c'est beaucoup
plus ciblé mais typiquement je cible
demain la France donc je vais aller
cibler les instructures les
infrastructures vitales donc les OIV qui
vont devenir EE et UI donc entité
sociale et entité importantes donc ça
concerne le bancaire les énergies les
télécoms globalement tout ce qui sert à
assurer la continuité de service de
notre pays. C'est comme si demain la
France se mangeait un rondomware et puis
bah comment on continue l'activité en
régime nominal de fonctionnement. Ça, je
pense que chaque état est en train de se
construire sa besasse qu'il se garde
pour lui. Et je me dis que peut-être
qu'à terme, surtout avec la vitesse à
laquelle les nouvelles technologies
évoluent, est-ce que ça ne risque pas de
devenir un peu comme le nucléaire une
sorte d'arme de dissuasion
cyber que chacun conserverait ? Parce
que typiquement ce qu'on voit sur du
Stucksnet, c'est du travail avancé sur
un ciblage local avec une finalité
politique. Puis il y a eu de
l'attribution qui a mis quasiment 10 ans
avant que ce soit pointé.
Plus rapide, on su de manière un petit
peu plus rapide mais officiellement le
fait que tu avais les Israéliens avec
les les Américains étaient aussi dedans
mais le fait que ça soit aussi vieux
c'était l'opération Olympic Game ça
s'appelait
2010 2009 c'est en fait ça ça a fait
trois mandats de présidents différents.
Tu vois donc
laisse le terminer. Ouais.
Donc euh je je sais pas pourquoi j'ai ce
pressent-là. Peut-être que je me trompe.
Par contre, sur un sujet qui va
continuer à à se développer, c'est
autour de la facilité avec laquelle on
peut aujourd'hui diffuser l'information
qui est fausse, euh faciliter une forme
d'influence deepake,
communication, deep fake. Quand je vois
les fermes de bottes en Chine, enfin
c'est juste technologiquement
aberrant les ce qui setup enfin ce qu'il
monte et qui ce qu'il configure en terme
d'infrastructure technologique. Et
effectivement, il y a un coup de retour
sur investissement comme l'évoquait
comme l'évoqué euh tout à l'heure avec
l'exemple de euh ça va peut-être coûter
500 € que de ou
de financer une opération pour qu'il y
ait cette retombée médiatique derrière
où finalement il y a cette approche
assez paradoxalement de retour sur
investissement. Je dirais pas
capitaliste vu le pays qu' en est à
l'origine.
Ah si si c'est capitalistes hein
maintenant c'est plus et ça je me dis
que par contre de par l'accessibilité
aux nouvelles technologies et notamment
li où le coût est de plus en plus faible
euh bah je vois pas de raisons pour
lesquelles ça continuerait pas de se
développer en sens. Après sur le vecteur
d'attaque où tu serais capable de sortir
donc N Z0 Day donc Z0 Day étant une
vulnérabilité sur un produit, un
applicatif par exemple tous les
routeurs, tous les parfeux, tous les VPN
de tels fabricant que tu sais déployer à
hauteur de n milliers ou centaines de
milliers d'instances sur une nation où
tu sais que si tu déclenches d'un coup
aujourd'hui c'est de l'arme numérique
qui se commercialise de plus en plus
cher sur le marché gris. Euh donc
aujourd'hui tu revends ça pourrait enfin
sur sur du produit grand public ou en
fonction des stacks technologiques sur
du zéroium en Israël tu à plusieurs
millions d'euros la vulnérabilité on
pourrait reprendre les devis qui avaient
liqué autour de l'affaire Pegasus
c'était quand même des c'est pas
monsieur et madame tout le monde qui a
les moyens de s'offrir ce genre d'arme
numérique et à quel point chacun on a
dans sa besasse et si demain souhaitait
faire un scénario catastrophe je pense
qu'ils auraient les moyens malgré
c'est c'est vrai qu'il y a une
prolifération du 0D tout à fait
comparable au nucléaire Et c'est pour ça
que je me dis, est-ce que chacun garde
pas un peu ça comme un secret de
polichinelle et à terme ça va prendre
une expansion que aujourd'hui qui sait
la mesurer concrètement parce que on
peut pas avoir de politique de
transparence totale, ce serait révélé
finalement
pour le coup la France est bien placé
pour mesurer la prolifération
et alors de ce qu'elle subit
non non non non ce qu'elle vuny
et plateform de Bugby buunty hein il y a
des plateformes Bugby Buunty qui sont
vraiment dans le 0D
en vent Il y a il y a un move que je
trouve super intéressant qui il y a il y
a un move que de la Chine que je trouve
super intéressant et qui en dit beaucoup
par rapport à ce que tu es en chez nous,
c'est que les mecs sont en train de de
commercialiser leur leur gros firewall
chinois à des États maintenant en
Afrique. Donc euh ce que tu viens de de
développer, c'est super rigolo parce que
moi c'est l'une des théories que j'ai
rigolo. Enfin, ben c'est rigolo parce
que ça rejoint en fait l'une des
théories, c'est l'une des théories euh
que je me suis faite comme ça dans mes
scénarios un petit peu débile. C'était
qu'on qu'on arriverait à un
recloisonnement en fait de d'internet,
tu vois, état par état.
Une balcanisation, c'est c'est Ouais.
Une vraie balcanisation d'internet.
C'est une théorie que j'ai depuis plus
de 20 ans en fait. Tu
je me rappelle avoir causé de ça en
école de commerce, tu vois. Donc si
je vais poser quelques questions
internet parce qu'on va on va continuer
cette discussion
autour d'une petite
euh attention, va y avoir le larsen de
de dans le son, tu t'oublie pas.
Alors euh questions internet, je les
prends, je les lis, vous les choisissez,
d'accord ? Euh bonjour. Serait-il
possible d'expliquer lors de l'interview
ce qu'est un VPN et ce qu'il n'est pas
et lequel lesquels sont bien ? On peut
pas faire de recommandation de produit
les gars. Ceux qui sont à éviter parce
que fake VPN VPN n. Merci. Deuxème
question deème question. Pouvez-vous
parler des fuites de données des
entreprises qui aussi voir surtout dû à
des prestataires mal ou pas sécurisés ?
Boîte de consultant entre parenthèses.
Merci. Bonsoir à tous. Bonsoir.
Pas vraiment une question, je me permets
de souligner l'accessibilité de
Bluetooth et de Fabric sur X pour
discuter. Oh les gars, c'est bien fait.
Nous sommes pé d'
proche de son public. C'est bien, c'est
les intermittents du spectacle de X
instructif et les remercier de ce
dialogue avec tous. Bonsoir. Pour ceux
qui souhaitent nous fliquer
ne font pas eux-mêmes preuve de
transparence et nous en nous affichant
leur relation d'intérêt avec nombreux
lobby et possible service secret
étranger tentant de faire de
l'ingérance. Point d'interrogation entre
parenthèses exemple Ursu Vanderl et ses
contrats coûtant de milliards passés par
SMS fermer la parenthèse. Bon ça ça
n'engage que celui qui pose la question.
NewP euh recommanderait-il d'utiliser
Proton ? On peut pas faire poser ce type
de question. Euh l'application de
messagerie vide, on peut pas poser ce
type de question. Avec le DPI, le VPN ne
protège que la que bien
superficiellement la vie privée. Entre
parenthèses, ne pas afficher directement
l'IP fermé la parenthèse. Non, point
d'interrogation. Développer développer
NIM. On l'a développé un petit peu les
LLMS
comme agent d'influence pour
l'interrogation. et LLMs pour prendre la
température mieux que nous l'ont fait
mieux que nous que nous l'ont fait les
RG Mistral comme perle française ou
simplement
Steam Microsoft pour interrogation
les punaises de lit à Paris contre planc
pour sauver les deux cinémas affectés
euh s'il devait donner trois conseils
d'hygiène numérique à faire en priorité
bon vous avez VPN, vas-y sur les VPN
parce que ça il faut que ça fait ça
fait toujours sortir de la Colombie avec
ton VPN ou non ?
Panama. Panama
ouais cétait au Panama moi. Euh donc
qu'est-ce que ça fait ? Qu'est-ce que ça
fait pas ? Un, ça rend pas anonyme,
c'est pas un outil magique qui rend
anonyme. De ça chiffre ton trafic d'un
point à un point B mais pas du point B
vers Internet.
Donc ça rend pas anonyme, ça ne chiffre
pas l'ensemble du trafic de bout en bout
jusqu'au destinataire. Ça permet juste
de d'avoir un petit peu plus de
confidentialité entre toi et internet
pour cacher à ton fournisseur d'accès
principalement ce que tu ce que tu vas
ce que tu vas visiter. Donc c'est pour
ça que si votre fournisseur d'accès vous
propose un VPN, posez-vous la question
du bien fondé du truc.
Ouais, c'est une bonne une bonne
intention. Ça ça peut être très très
bien pour aller enfin voilà pour aller
jouer sur Winamax Belgique ou je sais
pas quoi.
Ça peut être non
j'en sais rien. C'est enfin oui oui
parce que je suis désolé
Poly Market mais c'est pareil parce que
c'est c'est un site de Paris en ligne
c'est c'est la même.
Mais le gambling crypto pendant le
Non, je pas aller jusque là. Non, pour
les market c'est mais
mais non, on fait pas la promotion de
jeux d'argent ici.
Voilà, c'est pas une solution de
sécurisation, c'est pas une solution
d'anonymat, c'est un truc qui va
simplement permettre de
de rajouter une petite couche de
confidentialité. C'est un c'est un outil
à utiliser en plus d'autres choses.
La vraie question, c'est de qui tu dois
te protéger ?
Bah, c'est toute la question que tu dois
te poser en fait avant de d'allumer ton
VPN, d'allumer Thor, d'allumer NIM,
d'allumer ce que tu veux. Euh si tu te
protèges de l'État français, j'ai envie
de te dire que tu es dans la merde parce
que enfin c'est enfin peu compliqué.
Dans l'État français, ça va. Si tu
protèges l'État américain, tu es dans la
merde.
Si tu te protèges si tu te protèges des
régies publicitaires, un VPN est un très
bon outil. C'est euh c'est en plus d'un
navigateur avec des adblockers, des
trucs comme ça, c'est très très bien.
Euh si tu sais de quoi tu te protèges,
ben tu sauras quel type de solution
utilisé et en l'occurrence quel VPN.
Sachant que la première question à te
poser, c'est un qui a derrière euh de où
est-ce que les données partent ? Euh
qu'est-ce que tu veux protéger ?
Et les trois enfin en fait la première
c'est qu'est-ce que tu veux protéger
tout simplement.
Et alors on peut pas faire de
prescription
ni de diffamation.
Mais sachez
il y a pas de ma il y a pas de mai.
Non non je je cite pas de marque. Je
cite absolument que marque.
D'accord. Mais tu te débrouilles pas
pour donner une chaîne pour qu'on
prenne. Je te je te vois.
On va dire que le plus connu du marché
est celui qu'il faut éviter. Absolument.
H
et je n'en dirai pas.
Mais non, il a
et
je peux je peux te faire la partie fuite
de données si tu veux.
Merci, c'est très gentil de ta part.
Euh sur le volet fuite de données par
rapport à la recruescence. Alors la
recruescence, on la ressent aussi avec
l'effet médiatique de bon bah cette
semaine c'est un tel un tel un tel. Si
vous voulez avoir un suivi à peu près
exhaustif et des tendances, il y a le
site bonjourlaafite.org,
vous y allez, il y a une super
chronologie de qui a fuité, euh quelle
typologie de data affueté, les
volumétries approximatives. Euh donc ça
vous permet de suivre un peu l'actualité
bin aussi.
Il y a pas les datas.
Ah non non non, il y a pas la data
aujourd'hui, je rappelle sur le volet
législatif
conservation et traitement de données
fuité ou c'est une forme de recelle sur
un plan sur un plan pénal. He on s'amuse
pas. Merci. Elle
est connecté elle est collectée. Euh
posé la question de comment est-ce qu'on
limite la casse ?
Je sais je donne pas le nom du forum,
je vais fâcher.
D'accord.
Euh sur le volet responsabilité des
prestataires de services tiers
puisqueaujourd'hui je prends un exemple
simple. Je suis une entreprise dans
l'agroalimentaire. J'ai à date en 2025
si j'ai fait un bout de transformation
numérique de digitalisation tous les
termes que tu à la mode qu'on pourrait
sortir tu as un système d'information.
tu as de l'outil informatique, tes
collaborateurs, ils sont plus ou moins
sensibilisés. Donc pour j'en profite
pour celui qui pose la question de geste
d'hygiène numérique, on va pas en donner
que trois, c'est vous allez sur le site
de l'ANC, c'est gratuit, il y a des mou
en ligne, il y a le référentiel un peu
plus technique, les 42 règles d'hygiène
numérique et ces mou vous pouvez les
passer, ça vous sensibilise sur le
risque cyber au sens large. Cyber
malveillant, c'est très bien aussi pour
vous aiguiller, vous soyez dans une
conjecture pro, perso, sur les
plateformes de signalement si vous
subissez un acte de cyberversation.
et je finirai par taper sur l'écosystème
de prestataires et de fournisseur de
solutions numériques existant à ce jour.
Non, tu ne tapes pas, tu es bienveillant
et tu donnes des recommandations.
Alors, je vais être factuel.
Euh aujourd'hui, ces entreprises qui ne
sont pas acclimatées à l'outil
informatique sont clientes de ces
solutions. Qui dit client dit contrat.
contrat majoritairement signale à Vavite
dans lequel dans 90 % de ce que je vois
sur le terrain, on leur dit "Avez-vous
une clause qui concerne la cybersécurité
dans le contrat du produit que vous
utilisez ? Potentiellement vous payez
30000 € de licence par an ?" La réponse
majoritaire est non. La réponse, elle se
pose. La question se pose généralement
quand l'incident cyber survient. Et si
on se renseigne un peu dans la presse,
il y a eu des incidents depuis plus d'un
an d'acteurs qui fournissaient des
solutions e-commerce
de retail, donc les systèmes
d'encaissement dans les boutiques
physiques, de CRM pour gérer tous ses
clients, les le business qui arrive dans
l'entreprise où on a des clients de ces
solutions là quand l'infogère ou le
fournisseur de la solution se fait
attaquer euh se retrouve sans rien du
jour au lendemain avec potentiellement
une communication de crise de la part du
fournisseur de services qui est juste
catastrophique, qui respecte pas les les
délais légaux en vigueur. Donc 72 heures
de signalement à l'ACNIL, merci le RGPD
qui potentiellement va communiquer
auprès de ses clients, va attendre 10
jours, 15 jours parce que ils vont
peut-être mettre aussi 4 5 à déclencher
la crise parce qu'il y a un weekend
entre les deux. Et derrière, on se
retrouve avec 100 entreprises euh qui
nous disent bah si enfin pas tous hein,
mais dont certains quand on est sur une
PME avec trois collaborateurs qui dit
bah j'ai plus mon stock, j'ai plus ma
base client, mes systèmes d'encaissement
en boutique, bah finalement vu que c'est
plus connecté avec mon serveur dans le
cloud, c'est une brique technologique
hein, je peux plus en rien en faire. Si
à la fin du mois, j'ai pas solutionné la
problématique, sachant que moi ce que me
dit mon fournisseur de solution c'est il
y a plus de data, bah je mets la clé
sous la porte. En fait, je me positionne
en liquidation judiciaire. Donc Nice 2
aujourd'hui ça va être un vir levier
sauf que c'est français on a on a on a
du retard et l'Union européenne le sait
qu'on a du retard à transposer cette
loi. Nice 2 tend vers une
responsabilisation de ces chaînes de
prestataires et fournisseurs de
solutions numériques de manière d'autant
plus drastique dans des secteurs comme
la santé.
Les éditeurs logiciels avec le CRA qui
arrivera en 2027, même chose, est censé
remettre une surcouche d'exigence cyber
à l'égard de ses fournisseurs de
solutions. Mais il est temps d'arrêter
d'avoir des clients et là je parle à
titre personnel qui viennent me voir en
disant je pourrais je me tire une balle
dans le pied en disant ça mais c'est
aussi dans le but de de de comprendre
vers là où on doit tendre.
Quand un client vient me voir en disant
"J'aimerais tester la sécurité de mon
système d'information." Il y a ce qu'il
a donc ses serveurs internes. Donc ils
sont dans son périmètre de
responsabilité. sous réserve que ce soit
pas géré par 1/3. Il y a son logiciel RH
dans le cloud, il y a son système de
paye dans le cloud. Euh donc ces
clients-là, on les accompagne mais
surtout on leur passe le message de leur
dire ce n'est plus à vous, on arrête les
bêtises de payer le coût la de l'état
des lieux de la situation technologique
des outils numériques que vous utilisez
parce que bien trop souvent ils font
l'audit et on met en exerg les
vulnérabilités et c'est eux qui portent
le coût de le l'audit. On va voir
l'éditeur avec le rapport d'audit
gratuit et la réaction qu'on a en face
c'est il y a pas de problème, je vous
fais la montée de version et je vous
corrige les vulnérabilités. Voilà le
devis de mise en conformité et ça il est
temps que cette situation elle s'arrête.
Donc Nice 2 et CRA ça fera comme du
RGPD, ça va mettre 6 ans à être appliqué
en production. Je suis parce que déjà il
y a une tolérance pas tacite mais très
explicite qui a été communiquée de vous
avez 3 ans pour Nice 2 pour vous
l'approprier vous mettre en conformité.
Il faut qu'on arrête les bêtises sur ces
sujets-là et qu'on réagisse. Donc
conseil aux clients de ces solutions
numériques qui sont pas spécialisé dans
le métier de l'informatique, vous prenez
tous vos contrats avec vos services
admin et juridiques. Vous allez taper à
la porte de chacun de vos fournisseurs
de solutions et vous regardez la réponse
et la réaction que vous avez en face.
S'il y a une politique de transparence
qui vous file le dernier rapport d'audit
qu'ils ont fait, bah vous pouvez les
applaudir et vous les conserver pour 10
ans. Sur ceux qui vont mettre 3 mois à
répondre vont vous envoyer un Word
construit avec un pseudo extrait de truc
de l'ANC. Mais il y a rien de concret
sur demain, il y a un incident,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Qui porte la responsabilité au tribunal
? Qui paye les indemnités ? Quels sont
les temps de remise en conformité ? Et
il y a une politique de l'autruche où on
a caché la poussière sous le tapis.
Posez-vous les bonnes questions. Voilà,
c'est c'est vachement bien ce que tu
viens de dire parce que enfin c'est tout
le le le décalage qu'on a en fait
aujourd'hui entre les process qui sont
foutu en place dans pas mal de sociétés
sur le je pense à l'ISO 27001 où tu as
des mecs qui vont cocher des qui vont
cocher des des cases en fait sur des
tableurs Excel.
Voilà, le truc est complètement lunaire
en plus. Bon ben ça on a fait GG. Ouais
ouais vas-y. Donc le truc se discute à
la cafette. Le le truc se discute à la
cafette, mais en fait dès que tu as
besoin d'opérationnel euh dès que tu as
un souci avec le sale bidu qu'il faut
pas nommer et que tu t'appelles par
exemple marque de voiture qui fait des
voitures électriques super luxe
maintenant et que c'était pas le cas
avant qui se retrouve là depuis des mois
à ne pas pouvoir se débarrasser en fait
de de la merde qu'elle a sur son récit
et qu'ils étaient déjà de doigts de
[__] le le la clé sous la porte. Mais
ouais, enfin c'est il y a un décalage
qui est qui est qui est ouf et c'est là
les années qu'on qu'on va perdre encore
avec ce trucl avec l'application, la
transposition de telle bidule, de tel
machin, c'est une lourdeur, c'est aux
entreprises tout de suite de sortir les
doigts et enfin de de repenser en fait
le régime numérique. C'est s'ils
attendent les lois, c'est c'est mort.
avant avant que tu nous fasses une un
petit un dernier commentaire,
soutenez-nous sur Tipi, c'est grâce à
notre communauté qu'on peut organiser ce
type d'interview et résister à tout ce
climat médiatique et géopolitique
délétaire. Vas-y, Bris.
Mini anecdote, euh c'est que depuis 24
euh pardon 19 novembre 2024 que pour la
première fois donc c'est tribunal cours
d'appel de Renn qu'on a enfin une
victime euh d'une cyberattaque par
rançon logiciel. qui s'est retourné
contre son fournisseur de solutions
numériques. Donc littéralement ce qu'on
appelle son infogéreur qui lui filait
son infrastructure, ses sauvegardes et
qui a gagné en appel au bout de 6 ans de
procédure pour faire valoir le fait que
le fournisseur de solutions numériques
avait manqué à ses obligations de
conseil.
Mais même chose, ça c'est une première
d'une part et de deux, lorsqu'on lit le
PV qui est disponible sur internet, le
procès verbal de la conclusion de du
tribunal, ils ont touché 50000 €
d'indemnité qui correspondait au coût de
la réponse à incident, donc ce qu'ils
ont payé au prestataires caronstruit le
SI, la perte d'exploitation, la moitié
des collaborateurs au chômage technique
n'a pas été valorisée. Donc c'est vous
dire l'état de maturité aussi dans
lequel on est, mais il y a une vraie
dynamique qui est en train de se créer
sur laquelle il faut capitaliser.
Je je lis encore deux trois questions.
Y a-t-il des rapports faisant état de
problèmes d'amplification
ou de développement de maladie mentale
provoquée par l'intelligence
artificielle ? Peut-on utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle pour repérer
des enfants victimes de maltraitance
dans le cadre familial ou ailleurs, je
sais pas s'ils vont être capables de
répondre à ce type de question. en
analysant leur communication sur les
réseaux sociaux points d'interrogation.
Quelle serait la valeur morale d'un tel
procédé ? Bonne question. Euh quels sont
les lobby qui poussent la surveillance
en France pour interrogation par exemple
la validation de l'âge sur internet et
chat contrôle de plus en plus poussé.
Merci d'éviter les faux d'orthographes
les enfants.
Est-ce que Lia va-t-il nous gouverner
dans un futur proche pourinterrogation ?
Donc là, il y a eu l'alerte critique.
Euh peuvent-ils parler de menaces comme
Pegasus, des Malwar qui s'inscrivent
plus dans un schéma d'influence et de
menaces géopolitique sur lesquels on a
très peu de leviers entre parenthèses
techniquement et juridiquement ?
Bonsoir. Pouvez-vous demander à ces
trois monsieurs ce qu'ils pensent de la
théorie dite de Dead Internet Théorie ?
H
c'est quoi ? C'est le kill switch ? Non
non, la dette intern c'est la théorie
qui voudrait que euh les contenus et les
humains sur internet ne soient en fait
que de l'intelligence artificielle.
Alors, c'était une théorie consp qui qui
qui se se complaisait en tant que
théorie conspie à l'époque. C'était
complètement invraisemblable d'un point
de vue technique, hein, ça date une
petite dizaine d'années, mais
aujourd'hui, c'est une vraie
possibilité. Le nombre de faux humains
sur les réseaux sociaux,
50 % de
Bah, imagine-toi rien que sur un site de
rencontre ce que tu peux faire quoi.
Ouais, tu vois, c'est tout de suite
vachement rentable. Non, mais tu vois
c'est des enfin on sait qu'il y a un
déficit sur les sites de rencontre de
femmes. Il y a il y a plus d'hommes que
de femmes. Euh tuas un petit un petit
truc de d'intelligence artificielle qui
va te générer et te faire causer en fait
des profils de femmes. Bah ouais, c'est
peut-être une révolution pour ce type
d'activité. Donc enfin
et puis pour faire des opérations
d'ingérence, tu déploies des des
milliers de faux profils.
Astrourfing à Google. Astrotorfing à
gogo, faux profil géré par des IA qui
vont non seulement être capable de
converser avec toi de façon très
convaincante, mais que tu vas pouvoir là
encore avec une coordonné pour aller
infiltrer un groupe, se confronter à un
groupe ou au contraire s'insérer dans un
groupe avant après les élections. Si
c'est pariat les les la problématique de
coût s'effondre, donc tu tu peux
vraiment avoir des visions très très
long termes, surtout si tu es une
dictature et que tu tu te fous
totalement de tes propres élections.
Donc tu peux avoir une vision très long
terme. Ça n'a rien d' vraisemblable.
D'ailleurs, le le Pentagone s'est fait
griller à passer des appels d'offre
publique autour de ça, mais c'est
certainement pas les seul. Tu peux
aujourd'hui techniquement
on s'est fait griller en Afrique,
pas avec Delia. Non, non, c'était
c'était Manuel. On est en train de
passer d'une époque où il y avait bah
les fameuses armées de troll que que
Poutine a popularisé qui étaient des
gamins dans des call center qui opérait
des opérations plus ou moins réussies
avec des conditions de travail
dégueulasses, un turnover énorme donc
une qualité médiocre à la même chose
gérée par des IA et et j'insiste, l'IA
gère aussi bien le le faux personnage
qui va être capable de discuter avec toi
que la coordination de tout un groupe de
personnages qui va être capable
d'attaquer un autre groupe désigné pour
s'infiltrer à l'intérieur ou au
contraire rentrer en confrontation de
façon à déployer des des opérations
vraiment très très significatives. Tout
ça va passer en mode et donc pour
revenir à la internet théorie c'est une
théorie qui veut que de plus en plus de
contenus et d'individus que tu vas
rencontrer sur internet sont générés par
des IA et que il y a de moins en moins
d'êtres humains dans tout ça et c'est de
plus en plus crédible alors que c'était
complètement impressemblable il y a 10
ans.
D'ailleurs, Fabricier Pelmoin est un
robot
d'ailleurs.
Bonsoir. Merci l'équipe. Que pensez-vous
des alertes lancées par le collectif POS
IIA ou entre parenthèses ou POSE IA en
France. Les risque majeur qu'il dénonce
en matière de destruction d'Internet
voire de l'humanité par l'intelligence
artificielle vous semble-t-il plausible
?
Il y a pas de bouton pause.
Et si c'est Non, mais il y a un kill
switch aux États-Unis.
Oui, mais on n'est pas aux États-Unis.
Et si certains risques semblent
plausibles, vous semble-t-il évitable
par le simple la simple sécurisation
humaine de nos réseaux ? Il y a question
les enfants. Je vais
vous avez envie de parler de la loi
narcotrafic narcotraficotage de la
surveillance.
Bluetooth c'était IRC avant ICQ AOL le
les premières campagnes de péo bien sûr
il n'était pas dans le cas à toute
l'époque il parlait quasiment en direct
c même hein.
Ouais il parlait quasiment en
directement. OK.
Pourquoi personne ne parle du problème
de facture numérique centralisé des
risques énormes d'ingérence et de
surveillance des affaires ? OK.
Bon, vous avez envie de répondre à une
question pendant que j'essaie d'en
piocher une
en hygiène numérique, pas sur le volet
cyber mais sur le volet informationnel.
Euh moi je répète toujours les mêmes
conseils, c'est qu' il faut manger
équilibré et il faut manger cinq fruits
et légumes par jour. Je veux dire c
fruits légumes par jour toi
dans mon alimentation. Non, mais en
terme d'alimentation informationnelle,
oui. Euh, je m'efforce de consommer des
médias avec lequels je suis pas d'accord
et je me méfie comme la peste des
informations qui me brossent dans le
centre du poil. quand quand je reçois
une information et que ça me fait
plaisir parce que ça va vraiment dans le
sens que j'ai envie d'entendre, je m'en
méfie beaucoup plus qu'une information
qui me déplaît fondamentalement
et et souvent celle qui me déplaît
fondamentalement, je vais avoir tendance
à aller la vérifier
parce que c'est celle qui va me
permettre de développer mon point de
vue.
C'est l'esprit critique aussi
c'est l'esprit critique. et l'esprit
critique a totalement avec la Charlie
Kurk, on a vu l'azéthétique
s'effondrer comme une merde en en en
allant mais à fond dans tous les biaiss
qui lui faisaient plaisir. C'est c'est
catastrophique he l'esprit
indépendamment de la zéthétique qui est
un épiphénomène le le la mort de
l'esprit critique du fait que dès qu'un
événement émotionnel et la la scène
Charlie Kerk était vraiment un événement
émotionnel tout le monde se précipite
pour aller conforter un billet plutôt
que de chercher une vague vérité ou
juste d'attendre patiemment que les
investigations so
Trump le premier Trump premier s'il y a
bien un mec à blâmer là-dessus je suis
désolé
non alors là pour le coup pour pour
excuse-moi qui a dénoncé le premier
l'extrême gauche machin enfin voilà rien
toujours est-il que là on est 4 jours
après son assassine là clairement ça
désigne l'extrême gauche et on a tout un
carton
Elon Musk quand on lui demande en fait
qui était réellement Charlie K qu'est-ce
qu'il avait dit qu'est-ce le premier
truc qu'il a fait c'est on va corriger
Grock tu vois donc oui
oui mais je suis pas en train de te
défendre te défendre la droite américain
ce que je te dis c'est que à l'occasion
de cet événement là on a eu de la part
d'un camp qui habituellement jouait les
facteurs et les les défenseurs de la
vérité, ils ont plongé dans la théorie
conspie la plus crasse. Mais plus con
mais non mais l'autre c'est pas étonnant
l'autre il a une tradition il respecte
ses traditions. Ce qui est
catastrophique c'est que on avait
vaguement et encore depuis le Covid
c'était discutable un camp qui
s'attachait à la vérité au débats
contradictoir à la rationalité
au fait scientifiques. Il a disparu
Corséam
grâce à Trump ou à cause de Trump mais
clairement aujourd'hui tout le monde a
basculé dans la théorie consp et à la
moindre information qui a une résonance
émotionnelle tout le monde bascule dans
la théorie cons
c'est pour ça qu'il faut toujours
trianguler une information toujours
penser contre soi-même se midhydratiser
et consommer de l'information qui fait
pas plaisir.
Voilà on arrive à la fin de notre
interview. Je vais vous demander trois
conseils pour les jeunes générations en
mode vitesse lumière fa Millennium parce
que j'ai la dalle, on a de la route et
il faut que je fasse réchauffer la
bouffe. Et euh
Bluetooth, trois livres.
Ça va être toujours trois livres
et on va faire un livre.
Je vais Ouais, je peut-être deux un
livre et à nous trois on va en faire tr
Ouais. Allez. Ben en fait, si vous
voulez comprendre la géopolitique en ce
moment, ce qui se passe aux États-Unis,
ce qui se passe en Russie, ce qui se
passe en Europe,
lisez ou reliser le prince de Macavel,
ça me semble salvateur.
Bluetooth, serait-il possible que tu
expliques à Sky pourquoi il faudrait
utiliser Matrix Element au lieu
d'utiliser Discord ? Alors oui, parce
que c'est plus décentralisé mais en fait
Matrix et enfin Matrix en l'occurrence
qui est le serveur élément le client
sont pour moi euh pas compatibles avec
une confidentialité
blindée. J'irais plus volontiers vers du
Simple X faire du session pour ça.
Dernière question les gars. Quels sont
les films de science-fiction ou
d'anticipation qui vous semblent le plus
proche de notre réalité et du futur
proche ?
Matrix.
Non, pas pour
NCIS le vendredi soir.
NCIS le vendredi soir, non ? Où il tape
à deux sur un clavier pour combattre le
méchant envur russe
et et avec avec une anagotie collabo.
Oui, c'est ça.
Nous en Europe, on serait plutôt genre
c'est bah c'est ce avec quoi j'ai
grandi. He
fil, tu sais, il faut appeler internet
là. Je sais pas. Appelle internet. Skie
appelle internet.
Skelly appelle internet.
Skelie appelle internet.
Ouais. Voilà.
Idiocratie. Non,
on va y arriver.
c'est rassure.
Non non, ils y sont aux États-Unis. On
n'est pas tout à fait. On
est pas tout à fait encore ici mais aux
États-Unis c'est fait, c'est acté. C'est
Oua ou les États-Unis ont basculé. Donc
tu sais que l'année dernière tu sais que
Trump a annoncé que l'année dernière il
y a eu 300 millions de morts aux
États-Unis du Fantan là. Non,
il s'est trompé de 2-0. Non. Oui oui
oui. C'est comme le milliard, il est pas
très honnête avec les je te rassure ici,
c'est pareil hein
ça.
Lui il est président des États-Unis,
c'est plus gênant quand même. Fab
non mais attends, il est président des
États-Unis, on a eu tout un système
médiatique qui nous a fait les
États-Unis l'ont bien mérité.
Trump Trump est un symptôme, c'est pas
un problème. C'est un symptôme et et
c'est pas en se débarrassant du symptôme
qu'on va résoudre le problème.
Non, surtout que le problème c'est GD V
qui arrive après.
Non non non, c'est un symptôme aussi.
pas l'avir ton livre.
Tu vas pas l'avoir ton livre.
Donc alors mon livre, qu'est-ce que je
peux te conseiller comme livre ? Euh
R
il est J'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas lu cette
par contre je suis en train de de
commencer à relire un truc que j'avais
lu quand j'avais 20 ans qui est l'homme
l'homme révolté de Camu.
Euh c'est c'est par les temps qui
courent surtout aux États-Unis avec un
délire avec Dieu qui est assez
terrifiant. Euh je pense que c'est un
c'est c'est une bonne c'est une lecture
assez saine. L'homme l'homme révolté de
Camu.
Sex.
Euh bah ce sera pas un livre, ce sera
des PDF, je suis désolé. Ah bah si je
vais pas je vais pas inventer par
euh premier PDF pour ceux qui sont dans
la tech
en août cet été vachement intéressant
sur tout ce qui est protocole HTTP 1.1
qui déclare comme is dead qui ça fait 3
ans qu'il fait de la recherche là-dessus
avec des techniques de cash point
zoning. Enfin là c'est du trait écos
pour les les plus fru d'offensif sur le
chat. Euh pour les plus néophites qui
veulent s'intéresser à la cyber, le site
de l'ANC, tous les PDF, guide d'hygiène
numérique euh de manière les mou enfin
intéressez-vous, c'est de la ressource
gratuite pour le coup. Notre gendarme
étatique a fait un travail rédactionnel
qui est quand même costaud. Il y a même
de la ressource pour des PME qui n'ont
pas de budget, qui souhaitent s'y
lancer.
Merci Poupar.
Hm.
Merci Poup.
Oui, merci Poupa. Oui, effectivement.
Et pour finir, euh là c'est plus un
tips. Euh si vous recevez en ce moment
des appels à base d'IA, bonjour, vous
êtes peut-être intéressé euh euh pour
euh des informations sur les dernières
innovations énergétiques. C'est un vieux
loup de l'équipe qui l'a trouvé. Vous
lui répondez que vous êtes sous tutelle
et généralement elle brille.
Ah ouais
ouais.
Oh, c'est excellent ça
parce que j'en ai trois fois par jour
comme ça.
Elle vous fout la paix derrière. Ça
c'est le petit type technique
comme ça tout le monde est sérieux.
Très bon.
Vous voulez rajouter un mot ?
Allez, je te rajouter un deuxième
bouquin. En fait, je me le suis fait en
audiobook cet après-midi. C'est euh le
rêve d'un homme de d'un homme. Merde, ça
y est, j'ai un trou. Tu étais sour
le Ah [__] le rêve d'un homme quelque
chose. Le Dostoyki,
on va t'aider. On va t'aider.
C'est c'est un truc bon, c'est
désespéré. C'est c'est de la littérature
russe et tout ça, mais il y a un beau
message d'espoir. Tu l'écouté en version
originale ?
Euh non, pas en version originale,
voyons, je comprends pas le russe dans
le texte.
Le rêve d'un homme ridicule.
C'est ça exactement. Donc c'est une
réflexion sur l'absurde euh
et le rapport à la vérité derrière. Donc
ça voilà, ça pourra contrebalancer avec
le prince de Macave.
Ah, il y a une bonne question qui vient
de tomber. Je suis obligé de la
Allez dernière pour la route.
Est-ce que toutes les solutions dites
anonyme Telégram lavabite spider oak et
cetera ne sont pas vraiment anonyme ou
sécurisé ? Télégram
on trouve des failles.
Comment se Ah tiens, une question là.
Merci. Le fait que Pavel là il soit sous
clé française là
c'est c'est le prisonnier politique le
plus luxe de la planète.
Ça c'est vraiment c'est c'est l'extrême
opposé du présumé politique rusf
il est il est au crayon
donc ça va quoi. On a
il peut se payer le crayon.
Oui mais quand même enfin
c'est c'est quand même la classe qu pour
un prisonnier politique.
C'est normal pour vous. Non
non, par contre c'est pas normal de
l'ériger en défenseur de la liberté
bidule et tout ça mais
c'est tu vois voilà il y a un juste
milieu. Il y a il y a il y a une méthode
qui a été employée avec lui qui est qui
est à mon avis une forme d'approche. On
n'est pas au courant de tout. On connaît
pas la finalité du truc.
Euh maintenant les rigers en défenseur
des libertés, lui devoir prendre des
positions bidu grandilo à Elon Musk ou
je sais pas quoi. Moi ça me dérange
vraiment vraiment ça me dérange sur la
vie privée sur moi. Mais il fait la
merde vraiment
bah ouais sur la vie privée je suis
désolé Telegram tu peux pas dire que
c'est une solution pour ta vie qui enfin
voilà niveau confidentialité c'est de la
merde. Désolé je
mais il faut pas dire ça.
Bah si c'est factuellement de la merde.
Pas discrédité. Tu as des preuves pour
ça ? C'est justement le problème c'est
qu'on a pas de preuve justement tu vois.
Voilà, c'est que son son truc on peut
pas l'auditer.
Donc déjà partant de là, excuse-moi,
il est au crayon, c'est ça ?
Oui, il est pas donnez pas les adresses.
Comment se protéger comme on communique
Ah, pardon, excusez-moi. Comment se
protéger quand on communique avec ses
collaborateurs au sein du secteur
sensible ? Bah, le papier avec un peu de
jus de citron,
du Z, du
Non, des des des messageries. on va
citer plusieurs marques histoire d'être
mais des des messageries comme la base
ou ou scred c'est déjà beaucoup mieux
que du WhatsApp ou même des
contraignants à utiliser contraignant ça
suffit ça suffit ça suffit parce que là
on pourrait passer la nuit à faire ça
euh messieur merci d'être venu merci à
la communauté de nous soutenir merci
pour toutes ces questions. On n pas tous
pu toutes les poser ni y répondre. Il y
a des bonnes questions qui tombent. Il
fallait venir plus tôt les enfants. Euh
on vous dit à la prochaine euh on refera
une émission avec tout ça. On refera
plein de sujets. Messieurs,
bonsoir.
Bonne soirée. journée.
[Musique]